[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Greetings.
And welcome to the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
My name is Dan Carpenter,
and the Free Professor
of Government at Harvard and the
Director of the Social Sciences
Program at the
Radcliffe Institute.
We are here tonight
to experience
a reading of the play
Sliver Of A Full Moon.
Tonight's reading is supported
by the Harvard University
Native American Program, or
HUNAP, the Academic Ventures
Program at Radcliffe, the
Harvard Native Law Students
Association, Harvard
Divinity School, the Standing
Committee on Ethnicity,
Migration, and Rights,
and the Donald T. Reagan
Lecture Fund, with support also
from the National Indigenous
Women's Resource Center,
and the Office of the
President and Provost
at Harvard University.
Tonight's event
also marks something
of a critical event in a
much longer drama, namely
a set of events and
programs for the discussion
of vital Native
American and indigenous
issues, a theme running through
the 2015-2016 academic year
here at Radcliffe, and a
theme chosen in partnership
with HUNAP entitled "The
Performance of Native
and Indigenous Politics."
Radcliffe has embarked upon
this series of conversations
and events not because
the Institute has
particular expertise
in this area,
but because Radcliffe and
Harvard have clear needs,
and indeed, obligations
to enrich our dialogue
on native and indigenous issues.
A university is a conversation,
a highly bureaucratized
conversation to be sure, but
a vital dialogue nonetheless.
And it is vital to
the future of Harvard
and in deep consistency
with Harvard's native past
that the voice of Native
American and indigenous peoples
here be amplified
and strengthened.
I hope tonight's event can
play a part, even a small part,
in that strengthening,
in that amplification.
And it is with thanks
to HUNAP and associated
native and native studies
leaders at Harvard
that this process
has been renewing.
We at Radcliffe are
pleased and honored to play
a small collaborative part in
this much larger and longer
term dialogue.
Previous events in
the series of events
that we're talking about
here included a talk
at Harvard Law School by
Professor Angela Riley of UCLA
on indigenous women,
violence, and human rights.
She is, by the way,
with us tonight.
Also, a reading of poetry by
Anishinaabe poet and literature
scholar, Gerald
Vizenor and a lecture
last year by Yale
professor Ned Blackhawk.
Future events will include
a poetry reading by Luci
Tapahonso, the inaugural poet
laureate of the Navajo Nation,
a lecture by Native
Hawaiian writer,
Kristiana Kahakauwila
a photographic exhibit
by Matika Wilbur
of her Project 562,
surveying all federally
recognized Native American
tribes, and the conference
"Native Peoples,
Native Politics"
on April 29, 2016,
followed the next day by
the annual HUNAP Powwow.
Everyone here is
welcome to these events,
and I remind you that all of
these events I just mentioned
are listed in tonight's
program, and equally
on the Radcliffe website.
Now, let me introduce Shelly
Lowe of the Navajo Nation, who
serves as executive director of
the Harvard University Native
American Program.
Native and indigenous
students at Harvard
can testify to the warm and
supportive home away from home
that HUNAP provides.
They testify, in fact,
every day with their feet
as they hang out
in HUNAP's offices.
They're pretty comfy.
I've been there myself.
Shelly and her group
have demonstrated
amazing and energetic
commitment to
the Native American
community at Harvard
and to the joint programming
year at Radcliffe.
And I can speak for
everyone at Radcliffe
when I say that it
has been a privilege
to work with her and with
faculty chair, Doctor Dennis
Norman, community
coordinator Jason
Packineau, administrative
assistant, Samantha Hernandez,
and the entire HUNAP community.
We are honored, and
I am lucky, to call
them Harvard colleagues.
Shelly.
[APPLAUSE]
--[NON-ENGLISH] Dan, thank
you for those words.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
My name is Shelly Lowe.
I'm Navajo from Ganado, Arizona.
On behalf of HUNAP, I would like
to welcome everyone tonight.
And along with the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study,
I thank you for joining us.
I would like to acknowledge
the Wampanoag, Nipmuc,
and Massachusetts people whose
homeland we are on tonight,
and I want to thank you thank
them for their stewardship
and for their
continued leadership.
As I was preparing
for tonight's remarks,
I was struck by some
words in an article
about the young
Sicangu Lakota artist,
Frank Waln who
will be joining us
in April at one of our events.
The writer of the
article states,
"We are born into stories.
All of us.
We must learn to address
the sins of the past
so that we can
break and transcend
those cycles of
trauma and abuse.
These are the sorts
of messages we find
in art worth talking about.
As native and
indigenous people, we
are each born into specific
and very purposeful
creation stories.
We embody these stories, and we
continue to live in them today.
Many of us were
told these stories
at a very young age in
order to educate us,
or to teach us how to behave
in certain situations,
or to explain to us the natural
and the spiritual world that we
live in."
It seems quite often, though,
some stories were reiterated
to us by older
brothers and sisters,
or by aunties and uncles,
in order to scare us.
Naturally, many of our stories
are about negative entities
that often prey on our
people, particularly
our women and our children.
These bad entities
can take many forms.
They can be earthly beings.
They can be animal beings.
They can be spiritual
beings, and they
can be other human beings.
These beings can wreck
havoc on our people
in violent and deadly waste.
What our teasing family members
often neglect to tell us,
however, is that our
stories almost always
end with a defeat of
these negative entities.
Our stories give us solutions
and ways to defend ourselves.
They explain challenges
we must overcome in order
to acquire specific
weapons or behaviors needed
to defend the young, the
old, our women, and our men
from beings that
threaten or hurt us.
Our stories assure us that
we can be safe, healthy,
and strong communities.
Tonight, we are going
to hear a new creation .
Story the story is about a
threat to our communities.
It is about finding a way to
defend our women and children.
This story's being told to
us tonight to encourage us
and to remind us we can
overcome challenges.
Tonight's story, however,
doesn't have a complete ending.
In this story, we
are only beginning
to understand and gather
legal weapons needed
to defend our women.
Tonight's story
provides only a sliver
of the solution needed
to protect our futures.
Still, the message of tonight's
story are worth talking about.
Because the more
we tell this story,
the closer we'll come to
achieving a full moon instead
of a sliver of a full moon.
I want to invite Aharon
Kaslow, and Esther Labrado
to come up and say a
few words on behalf
of the Native American Law
Student Association at Harvard.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello and welcome.
My name is Esther
Labrado, and I am
a member of the North
Fork Rancheria Mono
Indians, California, and a
descendant of the Morongo
band of Mission Indians.
And as Shelly
mentioned, I'm also
the co-president, along
with Aharon Kaslow,
of the Harvard Native American
Law Student's Association.
And we are just so excited
to be here tonight.
And we want to say thank
you to HUNAP, and Radcliffe,
and to everyone else
who has worked so
hard to make tonight possible.
Harvard NALSA works
hard to foster
an educational and social
atmosphere for Native students
at Harvard Law School, and to
raise awareness and encourage
dialogue about issues facing
the Native American community.
We host and cosponsor events
throughout the school year
to further these
goals, which is why
we're so excited to be
part of this event tonight.
The issue is
incredibly important,
not just in the Native
American community,
but it's also important, and a
good example of why we're here.
The statistics about domestic
violence against Native women
are both staggering
and heartbreaking.
And the fact that for so
long, so many of those crimes
went unpunished is even worse.
As you will learn
through the play
and through the panel
discussion afterwards,
it was a law that allowed those
offenders to go unpunished.
And it is the law that has
attempted to change that.
This event is important to me,
not just as a Native woman,
but as a law student
and as a future lawyer.
I came to law school
because I wanted
to be able to more
effectively help others,
and to provide a voice for
those who so often go unheard.
If I can use my logically
to in some small way
help Native communities
on the issues
that they will continue to
face, I'll be forever grateful.
-As Esther said, my
name's Aharon Kaslow,
and I'm a descendant
of Ione Band of Miwok
Indians in Northern California.
And to echo Esther's
comments, I'd
like to think
Radcliffe and HUNAP,
and everyone else involved for
bringing this play to Harvard.
To me, A Sliver of a Full
Moon represents, actually,
a celebration of
Native communities
working and striving to improve
the lives of our Native women.
I mean, this is
especially important
because in my community and in
Native communities in general,
it's our tradition to honor
and respect our Native woman.
And while I was thinking
about what to say right now,
I realized that at
this point in my life,
I'm truly blessed to be honored
and surrounded by a bunch
of amazing Native women.
My co-president,
Esther, who takes
the lion's share of the work,
because she can manage it
better than I can.
Liz and Lauren are our
two 3L's who are extremely
successful at Harvard Law.
Maggie McKinley, Climenko
Fellow at Harvard Law,
who been an amazing mentor
and caring friend to me,
and Visiting Professor
Angela Riley who's
opened my eyes to the world
of federal Indian law.
I'm thankful to all
of you for helping
me continue to grow as a person,
a student, and a Native man.
I also want to thank
my mother, who I
don't think is here right now.
But she grew up
in extreme poverty
and faced conditions
that are too
common in Native communities.
Yet as a single mother, who
first without a high school
diploma, and now is a
doctoral student at Harvard,
worked her entire life to
ensure that I didn't experience
what she had to go through.
To me, she's the perfect example
of why our Indian communities
honor their women, and why we
need to continue this practice.
She and the other
native women I mentioned
work tirelessly for others
and for our communities.
And now I'm excited to
watch a play written
by another native woman, Mary
Katheryn Nagle, and a play
that I believe honors
this tradition.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-And we now welcome to the
stage Mary Anne Hendricks
with a blessing.
-Good evening.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Creator, Almighty
Creator, hear me.
First of all, I want to
acknowledge the Radcliffe
Institute and Harvard
University Native American
Program for giving
me this opportunity
to bless those who
have worked tirelessly
to bring about a very important
change in the Violence Against
Women Act.
We pray that the reauthorization
of our 2013 brings
hope to many, that
finally there will
be justice for the
horrendous treatment
that Indian women have
endured on reservations
throughout this country.
I also want to acknowledge
the first people on whose land
we stand and their ancestors,
and to bless the many tribes
represented here tonight.
We pray for the survivors
of domestic violence
those nightmares, physical,
and emotional scars
are reminders of what
love meant to them.
Yes, we know all too
well what PTSD is,
and healing is a long process.
We pray that children will
learn at an early age,
through teachings and examples,
that love means respect,
kindness, compassion,
and that it
is important to love oneself,
to expect fairness and equality
in any relationship.
We pray that Sliver
of a Full Moon
brings everybody
together with strength
to break the silence
of domestic violence.
-Thank you, Sachem Hendricks.
We will now begin the reading.
I wish to note that Diane
Millich of the Southern Ute
Tribe is unable to be
with us this evening.
And her role be occupied by
the playwright, Mary Kathryn
Nagle of the Cherokee
Nation of Oklahoma.
And now we present
Sliver of a Full Moon.
[APPLAUSE]
-[SINGING NON-ENGLISH]
-I remember where I was.
-I remember what I was doing.
-I remember what I was thinking.
-And I will never forget.
-I was on the
floor of the House.
-At my home in Fairfax.
-On my reservation.
-In Cherokee.
-In Alaska.
-Watching CNN.
-C-SPAN.
-Facebook.
-Watching the vote.
-Working for votes.
-I couldn't breathe.
-I was so nervous.
-All I could do was pray.
-What's the vote?
-30.
-We got 30?
-We need 218.
-We need your vote.
-You got my vote.
-31.
-Thank you.
-62.
-My whole life.
-I've dreamed of this.
-85.
-I've prayed for this.
-114.
-You've got my vote, Tom.
-Thank you.
-115.
-Everything depends on this.
-What if lose?
-We can't lose.
-Not an option.
-201.
-201?
-Oh, my god.
-I just prayed to Creator.
-215.
-Holy smokes.
-216.
-We got this.
-217.
-Is this for real?
-218.
-We did it.
-218?
-They're still coming.
-More votes.
-235.
-246?
-250.
-285.
-286.
-286 votes.
-I couldn't believe it.
-Unbelievable.
-I had to call Jacks
-Terry texted me.
-I just started texting.
-I started crying.
-I could hardly see who I was
texting, I was crying so hard.
-I had to scream.
-I scared my neighbors.
-I did victory dance.
-I prayed for my sister.
-It just seemed unreal.
-It felt like a dream.
-It was amazing.
-It was humbling.
-It was a miracle.
-What about Alaska?
-Next time.
-Why where we left out?
We were told--
-Everyone says--
-Alaska's different.
-Why are we different?
When Violence Against Women's
Act passed, I was watching TV,
and I started to cry.
The rate of violence against
Native women in Alaska
are higher than anywhere
else in the United States.
And yet, however,
we're always forgotten.
Violence like this in our
village did not always exist.
There was a time before the
United States, Alaska, a state,
a time when our tribal
government had authority.
If a man mistreated a
woman in our village,
our tribal government would
exercise its jurisdiction
and protect our women.
But when the federal government
made Alaska a state in 1959,
they took away our lands,
our culture, our language,
our jurisdiction,
and our safety.
Tribal sovereignty in
Alaska is a dirty word.
Most people want to
pretend we don't exist.
But the truth is
we're still here.
We'll always be here.
We will never leave.
Alaska, the state, has
a bit of dual mentality.
First it was the Russians
and fur, then the Americans
and gold.
Now, it's the oil
and the pipeline.
But my people, we have been
here for thousands of years,
from the time of the
glacier until now.
We were here before
the Russians.
We were here when they came.
Our men gave them fur.
And in exchange,
gave us the alcohol.
And then they took our women.
-This one.
-We had no choice.
-Just one night.
I'll bring her back.
-We had Columbus.
We had the Russians.
Tell me how is that different?
-This is my story.
-The story of my sister.
-My daughter.
-The story of my mother.
-And her mother.
-And her mother's mother.
-My grandmother.
-My granddaughter.
-This is the story of my life.
-Of my path.
-Of my people.
-This is my story.
-At first, it was
hard to share it.
-I had to keep it a secret.
-I was too ashamed.
-Too embarrassed.
-Too afraid.
-Scared.
-Forgotten.
-I was silenced.
-I thought I'd be judged--
-For something I never did.
-But then we came together.
-We stopped the silence.
-If I wasn't Native, my
story would be different.
-If I didn't live
on my reservation
-My story would be different.
-If I wasn't a citizen of
a sovereign Indian nation.
-My story would be different.
-I live in Alaska.
When it comes to
justice, that shouldn't
make my story any different.
-This is my story.
-And I'm here to share it.
One sunny afternoon in May,
I was returning my daughters
to their father,
per our agreement.
I dropped them off and
made sure he was home,
and they were in the house
before leaving, as usual.
But he walked out to
stand beside my car.
I stayed in the car
with the door locked,
but the car windows were down.
-[HUMMING]
-He was agreeable
enough at first.
But then he became
angry because I didn't
wish him a happy anniversary.
I stated that it
didn't seem appropriate
under the circumstances.
He suddenly lunged in the car
window and snatched my bag.
He got an address book, flipped
through it, and became angry.
He reached in and grab my
car key from the ignition
and walked away with keys.
And he was going
to throw the keys.
I live in the mountains
of Western North.
Carolina There are trees
and woods, things like that
all around everywhere.
And that was the
only car key I had.
And I thought, if
he throws that key,
if I don't have a way
to get out of here,
I don't know what I'll do.
So I was trying to get
the key, and he turned
and he finally said, OK,
you can have your keys,
and threw them on the ground.
So when I leaned down to
get my keys, he kicked me
and I rolled down a little hill.
At the time, my
youngest daughter
was standing beside my car.
I didn't even know
she was outside.
And I thought-- I thought
she was in the house.
But when I rolled down the
hill, I rolled role into her,
and she fell.
And he grabbed her.
I was trying to comfort her,
but he grabbed her hands,
and he pulled so hard, that I
was sliding across the ground,
so I let go.
But he went immediately
to the police station,
and he got there before me.
-Can I help you?
-I need to get a
protective order.
-OK.
Well, uh--
-Can you do that for me?
-We don't have jurisdiction
over non-Natives.
-My wife's enrolled, and she's
a danger to our children.
-Fill this out, and
we'll process it.
-It was so humiliating to
be sitting at the police
department with leaves and grass
in my hair, dirt on my clothes,
and clothes were torn.
On my side, on my rib area,
within the next day or two,
a bruise formed shaped
perfectly like his foot.
There must be
something you could do.
-He's enrolled.
-He has my children.
-And a protective
order against you.
So whatever you do,
don't go near them.
-He had my children, and all
I had was a bruise shaped
like his foot.
Maybe you've never heard
a Native woman tell
her story of survival before.
Maybe because you've seen movies
like The Last of the Mohicans
or Peter Pan, you think
at some point in time,
we ceased to exist.
But we're still here.
Some of us live on reservations.
Some of us live in suburbs.
We even live in Washington, DC.
-Hello.
Hi.
Excuse me.
-Do you need something.
-I'm Terry.
Terry [? Henry. ?]
-OK.
-Is this office on
Violence Against Women?
-You're looking at it.
-There's no carpet.
-Is that a problem?
-No, I just thought
that there would--
-You thought 'cause
today is your first day,
we'd roll out the red carpet?
-I thought there
would be carpet, yes.
-You work for the
federal government now.
You'll learn to do without.
Here's everything you'll need.
To start with, I want
you to draft the RFPs
that we sent to the tribes.
VAWA provides for a
significant chunk of change.
VAWA.
You know what that is?
-Yes.
-Violence Against Women Act.
-I know.
-We work to stop violence.
We don't promote it.
-I get it.
-Oh, and our
reports to Congress?
You'll be responsible
for writing those.
Basically, you'll be
doing all of the policy
work for the implementation of
VAWA grants in Indian country.
Any questions?
-Yes, just a few.
-Good.
And welcome.
can We do so much work
with Native Americans.
It's nice to finally
have one in the office.
-My mother.
She's a very beautiful
Indian woman.
And my stepfather, well, he
is a non-native, a white man.
And he's very abusive, ungodly.
The earliest that I remember
is being four years old,
when we were in
this trailer house,
and my mom was screaming.
I'm under the table.
I'm screaming.
The lights are off.
The lights are coming in
from the post from outside.
The door is here.
The couch is here.
The TV is here, and the
gun rack is right there.
And the table in the kitchen is
right here, and I'm under it.
My mom is screaming,
no, David, no.
And I see him grab the gun.
And he starts beating
my mother over the head
with the butt of the shotgun
until the only screams that
could be heard were mine, coming
from underneath the table.
And I think he beat to what
he believed was to death,
put the gun back on the rack.
He called her a bitch,
walked into the bedroom,
slammed the door, sat down on
the squeaky bed, and the thud,
thud of the cowboy boots
as they hit the floor,
and he laid down in
the squeak bed again,
and he went to sleep.
So I crawled over to my mom.
I'm crying so hard,
because I think she's dead.
So I put my face
down to her mouth
to see if I could feel her
breath, and I can't feel it.
And so then I
start crying again.
And I'm only four.
And I make myself stop crying.
I put my head down on her
chest to see if I could
feel it rising, and it was.
So I grab a blanket off the
couch, and I covered her up.
And I sat by her all night.
And if I fell asleep,
I'd get mad at myself,
because I'd hurry
up and check to see
if she was still breathing.
It's not that I
could have saved her.
It's just that I didn't
want her to die alone.
-This isn't an actress.
-Lisa set a survivor.
-I'm a survivor.
-We're all survivors.
-There are times he
would be chasing us.
And there was this field.
And as I grabbed my mom I
said look at that, Momma.
The moon is full.
And we crawled across this
field until we got to the woods.
And I took her to
my hiding place,
where we'd listen to him, to
his screams that would echo.
His screams about
how he was going
to kill us when he found us.
And she'd lay down,
and she'd go to sleep.
And if I thought I heard him
coming, I would wake her up,
and I would take her
deeper into the woods.
Because he had been in Vietnam.
So when I'd reflect back,
he was afraid of the woods.
He was afraid of the night.
In the woods, the
night, we were safe.
The moon was our sanctuary,
if we could make it.
-I found a rat this morning.
Yes, rat.
Underneath my desk.
And it ripped open
a bag of chips.
-You want me to buy
you a bag of chips?
-Look, I really
need to talk to you.
-About rats?
-About the grants
we're giving tribes.
-What about them?
-I'm not sure they're
making much of a difference.
-So give them to
different tribes.
-That's not the issue.
-What's the issue?
-Our women are raped.
They go missing.
They're murdered.
-And our office gives
tribes the money
they need to deal with that.
-Yes.
But after the fact.
-The fact of what?
-We come in after the
violence has occurred.
By the time the women
walk in the door
of one of our programs,
they're already a victim.
-Oh, yeah, right.
You're not a victim unless
something has happened to you.
Listen here, Pocahontas.
It's a miracle you can give
tribes any funding at all.
A lot of us here in
DC worked hard in '94
to get the Violence
Against Women's Act passed.
We don't have to ask for funding
for tribal domestic violence
programs, but we did.
You should be thankful
for what you have.
-Len Hootch and several
women opened day shelter
in Emmonak, Alaska 27 years ago.
It is still today
the only shelter
for Native women for the
entire state of Alaska.
When we opened, our
women had nowhere to go.
We'd find them hiding in
smoke houses and steam houses.
They'd tell our tribe, we
don't have jurisdiction,
that we don't exercise
any kind of authority.
When we call the state
troopers for help,
it takes two or three days for
them to arrive and to respond.
Our villages are so remote
where I live in Tetlin,
there is no road, so the
only way to come and go
is by airplane.
For three decades, this
shelter has been the only place
our women can go.
The state cut our funding.
-I heard.
-What's this?
-A grant from the
DOJ OBW office.
Enough to keep you open.
-I just put three
women on the street.
-Tell them to come back.
-One of the women, I just
asked her to leave her husband.
Tried to kill her.
-We'll get her a
protection order.
-She has one.
The tribe issued it last week.
-That's great.
-The state of Alaska
refuses to enforce it.
-How can they refuse to
enforce a protection order?
-They say we don't
have jurisdiction.
-What are you doing?
-What's it look like I'm doing?
I'm packing.
-Did you ask for time off?
-No.
-Our report to Congress is
due at the end of the month.
And I'm going to need you--
-I'm not coming back.
-What?
-I'm going home.
To Cherokee.
-I suppose the rats
were just too much.
-I'm done applying Bandaids.
-Our Bandaids make a difference.
They provide your
people with funding.
-My people don't
need your funding.
-Tribes do.
They want to provide shelter,
and food, and counseling.
-We have to do more than
give women counseling.
-Oh, you're right.
Please stand back and
let me wave my magic wand
and make all the
violence go away.
-We don't need your magic wand.
We need jurisdiction.
-My people, the
Southern Ute, we're
the only tribe in Colorado.
I've lived my whole life
here on our reservation.
Our reservation is our
land, and our jurisdiction
comes from the land.
Creator placed us here, so
we've been here since creation.
And this stripping of our
jurisdiction, this taking it,
isn't real.
But it almost cost me my life.
When I was 26 years old, I
started dating a non-Indian.
A white man.
I was in love.
Life was wonderful.
And after the bliss of dating
six months, we were married.
He moved into my house and
lived on my reservation with me.
To my shock, just days after
our marriage, he assaulted me.
I thought after the first
time, it wouldn't happen again,
but then it happened a
second time and a third.
So I called for help.
And then I called
for help again.
And again.
I called so many times, but
no one could ever help me.
-If you're so upset, why don't
you make one of your calls?
It's OK, baby.
I'll make it for you.
-Tribal police.
Is this an emergency?
-Well, not exactly.
-Can I help you.
-I just want to apologize.
Because you see, I got a little
carried away this morning.
And well, I hit my wife.
-Are you enrolled?
-I'm white.
-So you're not enrolled?
-Is that a problem?
-You've called before.
-Yeah, well?
-Nothing's changed.
If you're not enrolled, we
don't have jurisdiction.
-He says he doesn't
have jurisdiction.
You want to talk to him?
Thanks for your help, Officer.
When will you finally get it?
-He can do whatever he wants.
-They can't touch me.
-I picked up the phone.
-I made a call.
-I kept calling.
-No one responded.
-I must have called
a hundred times.
-Please.
Can't you do something?
-The answer was always the same.
-We can't.
He's not enrolled.
He's not Indian.
-So we don't have jurisdiction.
-But I kept calling.
-I called the police.
-Please help.
-Every time.
-911.
-I need your help.
-But every time I
called, no one showed up.
-They would just sort of report.
-They always let him go.
-I remember looking back those
police reports in eight font.
Years later, my mom asked
me to be her advocate,
so I pulled all of my
stepfather's police records.
And there were pages,
all of those 911 calls,
in eight point font.
Individual calls.
There had to have been at least
seven to eight, nine pages.
That's how many 911
calls we made for help.
And he was never, ever once
ever convicted for anything
he ever did to her.
-It wasn't always this way.
-There was a time before.
-Before 1978.
-A time when we
had jurisdiction.
-Before Oliphant
-I remember when
I read Oliphant.
-I can't believe it.
-My dad called me.
-Tribal council convened
an emergency meeting.
-Said you better read this.
-The Supreme Court
issued a decision.
-It's going to change our lives.
-1978.
-The Supreme Court
said we can't prosecute
non-Natives, non-Indians,
anyone that's not enrolled.
-The Court said we
can't prosecute them
if they come onto our
lands and commit crimes.
-1978.
-My stepfather, my
husband, he's non-Native.
-Not enrolled.
-And after Oliphant--
-He began to realize.
-After Oliphant--
-He figured it out.
-After Oliphant, he knew.
-It didn't matter
if I had bruises.
-Or cuts.
-Or bleeding.
-Or a broken bone.
-Because of Oliphant.
-He could kill me, and
it wouldn't matter.
-As soon as the Supreme
Court issued its decision,
our sisters from every corner of
Turtle Island went into action.
Our sisters in South Dakota
opened the White Buffalo Calf
Woman's Shelter, the first
shelter for native women
in the country.
The fight to restore
our jurisdiction
continued for several decades.
And in 2003, I was honored
to be at the first meeting
of our tribal
coalitions in Arizona,
when we created the National
Congress of American Indians
Task Force in Violence
Against Women.
We've come a long way since
that meeting back in 2003.
But I know we wouldn't
be where we are now
if we as Native women
hadn't to stood up.
If we hadn't demanded that our
tribal leaders listen to us.
Many of our tribal leaders
took our messages back home
to their own tribes,
and we watched
as our native women gave
birth to a national movement.
--[NON-ENGLISH], and thank
you for having me here today
to present.
-[NON-ENGLISH]
-Sorry.
-This is the Eastern Band.
You say [NON-ENGLISH].
-You're not in Oklahoma anymore.
-So how long will this take?
-Well, with what I'm
prepared to present,
not more than 40 minutes.
-No, I mean the campaign.
How long will it take
to get the bill passed.
Do you know?
With the tribal
jurisdiction provision?
-Well, with the
Congress, who knows?
It could take quite a while.
-Quite a while?
-Months?
Years?
-Nothing's guaranteed.
-We've been working
on this for years.
-I'm well aware.
-We sponsored the Wiping
of Your Tears ceremony
with Senator Biden, prepared
the draft for VAWA 2005.
-I remember that.
-But you think the time is now.
-We need them to act now.
-You need them to act now.
-This has nothing to do with me.
-Terri here is co-chair
of the NCAI Task Force
on Violence Against Women.
-We're proud of her appointment.
-It has no effect on
my service to council.
-Sure, it does.
-You're sitting
here telling us we
ought to advocate for
jurisdiction for everyone.
-Yes.
-Why should Eastern Band
foot the bill for everyone?
-Because we need jurisdiction.
-If I may interject--
-Please.
-I know it's a lot to ask, but
you won't be the only ones.
San Manuel stepped
up, and Chief Anderson
has promised the support of
the Choctaw, Tulalip Cherokee
Nation.
Muscogee Creek?
-I believe so.
-I hope so.
We can't do this alone.
-You won't be.
Everyone is helping.
See, we have to stop
thinking about this
as my tribe and their tribe.
Divide and conquer's been
the other side's philosophy
since 1492.
-OK.
But what are we really facing?
-Why, I'm not sure I
know what you mean.
-If we put money
on this now, what's
the chance we actually walk
away with jurisdiction?
-Well, it's going to
be very difficult.
-How difficult?
-Challenging.
-But not impossible.
-We couldn't get the Dems to
put it in the Law and Order Act
just last year.
-That wasn't a campaign.
-Well, if we can't
win the Dems, we'll
never reach the Republicans.
-This is different.
-Well, I'm being
honest with you, Terri.
-Councilwoman Henry,
Mr. Whitehawk.
And let me tell you something
about our tribal council.
Our tribal council
doesn't do things
because they're possible.
We do things because it's our
responsibility to do them.
It's our job to protect
every man, woman,
every child in our community.
And we know that if we
protect a woman in her home,
then we protect her children.
And that protects her house,
and the house next to her,
and the house next to that.
And so pretty soon, it's
the entire community
we're able to protect.
-Yes, but we need to be
realistic about what we can do
in this--
-This isn't about
what we can do.
This is what we should do.
And what we should do is
fight for this Congress
to recognize the
inherent sovereignty
we have as a tribal government
to protect our people.
-Put it to vote.
-All in favor?
-Aye.
-All opposed?
-Mr. Whitehawk.
You've authorized the lobby
on behalf of the Eastern
Band of Cherokees for the
reauthorization of the Violence
Against Women Act,
specifically to advocate
for the passage of the proposed
tribal jurisdiction provision.
Meeting's adjourned.
We'll send you the contract.
-Thank you.
-[NON-ENGLISH]
-Do we expect a
full court press?
-You'll get nothing less.
-Very difficult.
-This will be difficult.
-You know what's difficult?
Listening to women who've been
raped, abused, and battered
asking for help, and
having to tell them
there's nothing you
can do, because you
don't have jurisdiction.
-Hey, I was tribal police
before I went to law school.
Now, I'd get a call and
before I could help her,
I'd have to ask, where is she?
-Is she on land
that's tribal trust?
-Or land that's been sold?
-She could be on fee land.
-And you can't just
ask, where is she?
-You have to ask, who is he?
-Is he Indian?
Is he enrolled?
-Because if he's not--
-Tribal police don't
have jurisdiction.
-Heh.
Makes you want to
never answer the phone.
I'll get us two tickets
for DC for Monday.
-Two?
You're going to walk
the halls with me.
-I think you're confused.
I hired you.
Not the other way around.
-Hey, I'll do the work.
But I need you to be the voice.
-Why me?
-You're a woman and
a tribal leader.
You're Councilwoman Henry.
-Please.
Call me Terri.
-I'll have my staffer get
started on this right away.
-We really do think
now is the time.
Before this year's election.
-Of course.
The Republicans desperately
need women voters.
-And we can capitalize on that.
-Is there someone you can
reach out to across the aisle?
-Crapo's agreed to cosponsor.
-You're going to give
this to a Republican?
-Mike's good on Indian Affairs.
-Trust me, Terri.
No one's going listen to
a Democrat from Vermont.
-We need him on this one.
-OK.
-I'll have my staffer send you
a draft of what we put together.
-And you're serious about this?
-We're 100% with you.
-But are you really with us?
I'm not sure what you mean.
-When you can't get
the 60 votes you need,
what's going to be on
the chopping block?
-That's not how it works.
-Don't get cheeky with me.
-Terri.
-If it's anything like
the last 400 years,
do you know who will
be the first of all?
Not immigrants.
Not LGBTQ.
It'll be our Indian women.
-That won't happen.
This bill won't protect anyone
if it doesn't protect everyone.
-I promise.
We won't reauthorize VAWA
without the tribal jurisdiction
provision.
-Well, we got the Chair of
the Judiciary Committee.
That's a good start.
-What next?
We're scheduled to
visit Murkowski.
-What's wrong?
-I just got an email
from her staffer.
She canceled our meeting.
-Senator, thank you for moving
things around in your schedule
so you could speak with me.
-What do we need to discuss?
-VAWA.
-I made my position clear.
-We know you intend
to vote for it.
-There's not a woman in
the Senate who isn't.
-The folks back in Juneau.
-Your boss?
-The Attorney General thinks the
tribal jurisdiction provision
could use some editing.
-The committee's
agreed on the language.
-What about a clarification?
-I think the language
is pretty clear.
-Tribal jurisdiction
is only restored
to tribes in Indian country.
-You want me to reference
the Supreme Court's decision
on Venetie?
-What a great idea, Senator.
I wish I'd thought
of that myself.
-I told them to include Alaska.
I can't tell the committee
I change my mind.
-Tell them Alaska's different.
You and I both know there's no
Indian country left in Alaska.
-I was born in 1958.
Alaska wasn't a state then.
To me and to my family,
it was simply our home.
Growing up, I didn't speak
English until I was 12.
My first day at the
BIA school, the teacher
told me never speak Athabascan.
You speak English.
When I did speak in my language,
the teacher slapped my mouth
with a ruler, or my hands.
Sometimes, she
would pull my hair.
At first, I was
shocked, but BIA school
was the first time
I saw violence.
One day, after I got my hair
pulled, I ran home to my mom
and I told her, I'm
never going back.
They hit me if I
speak my language,
and I don't ever
want to go back.
She was silent for a long time.
And then she said, you have to.
If you don't, they'll
take you away,
and I might never see you again.
I learned at a very young
age that if I was quiet,
I was safe.
As a child, they taught
us for Native Alaskans,
silence was our only safety.
-The Senator can't meet with
you today, so it'll be me.
I'm sorry.
And you are?
-Terri Henry.
I serve on the Council of
Eastern Band of Cherokee.
-She's the co-chair
for the National
Congress of American Indians
Committee on Violence
Against Women.
-OK.
-Now we're here to
discuss Leahy Crapo.
If you've had a chance
to read the bill--
-Look, I'm going to
stop you right there
and be honest with you.
We're willing to stay
as late as we need
to tonight to work things out--
-And what's on the table?
-We'd like to propose
some language.
We brought our pajamas.
-Guess I forgot mine.
-Wait.
You removed jurisdiction.
-We replaced with
federal delegation.
-Well, that won't work.
-It has to.
-No.
Congress needs to restore
jurisdiction, not delegate it.
-Congress can't recognize
jurisdiction in Indian tribes.
-Why not?
-It's unconstitutional.
-No.
It's pre-constitutional.
We existed as sovereign
nations before you even
had this document you
call a constitution.
-Terri.
-The Supreme Court
was clear in Oliphant.
Tribes don't have jurisdiction.
I mean, over non-Natives.
You, of course,
have jurisdiction
over your own people.
-Just not your people.
-If this is your attempt to
charm the Senator into voting
for the bill, you're failing.
-Hey, we've got
the votes we need.
-In the Senate,
not in the House.
-I'm sorry.
Does Senator Cornyn get
a vote in the House?
-Look.
We're here to negotiate
a deal with you.
And you want to
negotiate with us,
so you're going to have
to negotiate with Cantor.
-I'd rather talk to Cantor.
-Fine.
-Thank you for your time.
-You might pass in the
Senate, but you'll never
pass in the House.
-We got to work on tone.
-Tone?
-We're asking people to
give us something we want.
-We're asking them
to give us what
they should have never taken.
-Well, I agree with that.
But it's 2012, not 1877.
We have to take what we can get.
-There was a time.
-Before now.
-There was a time
when we were safe.
-When we didn't have
this kind of violence.
-Not like we do now.
-Our men knew to view
women in the sacred manner.
-Not to say that we lived
in a perfect society.
-Because we didn't.
But we certainly didn't
live in a society
where women are
treated like this.
-It was never like this.
-They introduced it.
-When the soldiers
came to round us up.
-To send us on the
Trail or Tears.
-When they first put
us on the reservation.
-When they forced us to
go back to their schools.
-We had to hide.
-We had to go to the fort.
-To get our food.
-To get our ration.
-Our commodities.
-From the soldiers.
-And when we went to the
fort to get our food.
-What's this?
-I've come for my rations.
-We're all out.
-Please, sir.
I have children.
-I said we're all out.
-I have to feed my children.
-Come in back.
Are you deaf?
I said come in back.
You don't get something
for nothing around here.
You want to feed your
children, come in back.
-My grandmother.
-Our grandmothers.
-They were raped--
-By the government agent--
-For food--
-To feed their children.
-Raped by the soldiers.
-Just because they could.
-They had to run.
They had to hide.
-They had no choice.
-Our grandmothers.
-My grandmother.
-They're survivors.
-Survivors of war.
-They weren't targeted because
of the color of their skin.
-We aren't targeted because
of the color of our skin.
-We're targeted because of
who we are, as Indian women--
as Native American women,
-As Alaska Native women.
-Because we're citizens
of sovereign nations.
-Because we're sovereign women.
-It's been this way for 500
years, since the Russians came.
-Since 1492.
-Since 1978.
-We're still sovereign.
-I wish I could say
the war has ended.
-But we live in
conflict every day.
-It's time for a change.
-That's awful.
-It's the truth.
-I had no idea.
-Senator Brown.
Do you have a minute?
-This is coming from Crapo?
-I'm in no rush.
-Yes.
-Right.
-OK.
I'd like to talk
to you about VAWA.
-Senator Heller
wants you to know--
-The tribal
jurisdiction provision--
-You have his vote.
-Thank you.
You have my vote.
-For Leahy-Crapo?
-Yes.
-Well, thank you.
Senator Collins.
-Yes?
Do I know you?
-Dennis Whitehawk.
I represent the Eastern
Band of Cherokee--
-And you want to talk
to me about VAWA.
-Yes.
-I spoke to Patty.
-We have some questions.
-I like her answers.
-The tribal jurisdiction
provision is very important.
-You have my vote.
-Thank you.
-Senator McCain agrees.
You have his vote.
-Thank you.
But he doesn't think
it'll pass the House.
-Senator Snowe--
-We'd like to discuss VAWA.
-Sure.
-Jurisdiction is critical.
Without it--
-You have my vote.
-Thank you.
-And the vote of every
Republican woman in the Senate.
-That's great
-You look surprised.
We just-- I guess
I didn't you didn't
think a bunch of Republicans
would support you
on this let me
tell you something.
We may be Republicans, but
first and foremost, we're women.
-That's--
-A lot of Republicans.
-I talked Brown.
-I spoke to Snowe.
-McCain's staffer.
-And Heller.
-They said yes.
-We might have enough votes.
-Senator Moran wanted
me to tell you--
-Nope.
- --that Senator Rubio,
with all due respect--
-He can't vote for this.
-You won't change
my mind on this.
-Did he say why?
-If you can't
negotiate with Cornyn,
you can't negotiate with him.
-Let me get this straight--
-Big government
and inefficiency.
-The tribal jurisdiction
provision restores jurisdiction
at the local level.
-I'm sorry.
-You're taking authority
away from the state--
-I don't believe this.
- --and giving it to the Feds.
-That is not at all
what we're doing.
-I read the bill.
Senator Shelby wanted
me to tell you--
-McCain's voting for it.
-I'm Senator Lee.
Not McCain.
-His vote is no.
-Does he understand?
-I'm late for a meeting.
-Oh, Senator Toomey.
-Yes?
-I'd like to talk
to you about VAWA.
-Oh.
-I have a meeting
with Senator Weicker.
-He's not here.
-Look, the tribal jurisdiction
provision is very important.
-I understand your position.
-When will he be back?
-But I've made up my mind.
-We said we would discuss VAWA.
-I discussed it with him.
-My vote is no.
-He's against it.
-No?
-I'm sorry I can't help you.
-We just don't agree here.
-Thank you for your time.
-I spoke to [INAUDIBLE].
-Where's the White House?
-Well, they're fully on board.
-That's great.
-Leahy says they're
voting this week.
-Do we have enough votes?
-I don't know.
-I'm worried we don't.
-Senator Murray?
-I hear what you're saying.
-We have a right to this water.
-Everyone says they have
a right to the water.
-Yes, but this water is ours.
-Let me see what I can--
-We signed a treaty with
you, your government.
-Let me see what I can do.
-Thank you.
-Deborah, one more thing.
-Yeah?
-VAWA.
-OK.
-I need to be honest with you.
Sean?
I need you to tell Deborah
everything you told me.
Everything.
-The vote's most likely to
happen in the next day or so.
-That's great.
-The tribal jurisdiction
provision won't be in it.
-What?
-It's been taken out.
-What about the
immigrant provision?
-Still in there.
-LGBTQ?
-Still in.
-You realize we have tribal
members who are LGBTQ.
-Sure.
-They won't be protected.
Without jurisdiction,
VAWA will do nothing
to protect them on tribal lands.
-We don't have the votes.
-If we fight for tribal
jurisdiction now,
we'll lose the whole thing.
-We can't afford to
lose the entire VAWA.
-What about my women?
My citizens?
The women that I represent?
-We're so sorry.
-We wrote letters.
We came here to speak.
-It's been decided.
-I could hold--
-There must be
something we could do.
-I could hold a
press conference.
-You think that would
make a difference?
-It would if you
agreed to speak.
-I'm not a policy analyst.
-You're a tribal leader.
-Yes, but--
-You're in here talking me
about your treaty rights.
Isn't that what VAWA's about?
It's really my honor to
introduce to Vice Councilwoman
Deborah Parker, very courageous
in coming forward today
to talk personally
about why this
is so very important
to her and to so many
other Native American women.
-Thank you, Senator Murray,
Senator Boxer, and Senator
Klobuchar Good morning.
My name Deborah Parker.
I am an enrolled member
of the Tulalip Tribes
of the State of Washington.
I'm currently serving as the
Vice Chair of the Tulalip
tribes.
Yesterday, I shared
with Senator Murray
the reasons why the
Violence Against Women
Act is so important to
our Native American women.
I did not expect to be
sharing my own story.
I am a Native
American statistic.
I am a survivor of sexual
and physical violence.
My story starts in
the '70s as a toddler.
You may wonder, how do I
remember when this occurred?
I was the size of
a couch cushion,
a red velvet, approximately
2 and 1/2 feet couch cushion.
One of the many girls
violated and attacked
by a man that had no boundaries
or regards for a little girl's
life, or my own.
The man responsible
was never convicted.
In the early '80s,
at a young age,
I was asked to babysit
my auntie's children.
During a late hours
of the evening,
she arrived but was not alone.
Instead of up packing
my things to go home,
my sense was to quickly
grab the children.
The four or five men that
followed my auntie home
raped her.
I had to protect the
children and hide.
I could not save my auntie.
I only heard her cries.
Today is the first time that
I have ever shared this story.
She died at a young age.
The perpetrators were
never prosecuted.
A majority of our
girls have struggled
with sexual and
domestic violence,
not once but repeatedly.
My question for Congress
was and always has been,
why did you not protect me?
-Why didn't you
protect my family?
-My auntie?
-My mother?
-My daughter?
-Me?
-I am urging Congress to
uphold the US Constitution.
-Honor our treaty agreements.
-Recognize our sovereignty.
-Restore our jurisdiction.
-Thank you.
-What do you need, Deb?
-Me?
-You had anything to eat?
-I'm fine.
You've been at it
for days now, and I
haven't seen you eat a thing.
-I'm not hungry.
I brought you a sandwich.
-What do you think
of this sentence?
The tribal
jurisdiction provision
and the reauthorization
of VAWA 2013
recognizes the rights to
our native women to be free
of violence and
abuse, as well as
the inherent sovereign
authority of tribes
to protect their own citizens.
-Sounds good to me.
-Too many comments.
-I think it's fine.
-People stop listening when
you use too many commas.
-I don't think
people hear commas.
-I hear commas.
I hear commas all the
time, and they bother me.
You're a lawyer.
Didn't you spend years
studying where to place commas.
-I was tribal police
before law school,
and we never used commas.
-[LAUGHING]
-Now my dad, he was
obsessed with commas.
Whenever he wrote an
opinion or an order,
he'd spend hours revising,
deleting commas, adding commas.
He always said judicial
orders must command respect.
-He was a tribal judge?
-I never got to sleep
in on a Saturday morning
because he would drag me out
of bed and throw me in the car.
He would take me with to court.
And on the way,
he'd make me read.
Back then, to have a legal case,
it was a printout of a book.
So we'd drive, and sometimes
it was several hours.
And he'd say, OK,
read this to me.
And I'd read the
case to him, and he'd
say, what do you
think that means?
He was teaching me at a very
young age to respect the law.
-I thought about
going to law school.
-Don't.
-You went?
-I had to.
-Your dad made you go?
-You all don't have the TV on?
-What the heck are
you doing in here?
-We're talking.
-For crying out
loud, turn on C-SPAN.
-In a minute.
I need to concentrate.
-They voted.
-What?
-We won.
-Oh, my god.
-We got 68.
-We just passed the Senate.
-Thank you.
-OK.
We're hugging.
-We won.
-We still have to
pass the House.
-I gotta call my
husband and my kids.
-You didn't think we'd do it?
-I didn't think
we had the votes.
-We didn't until
the last second.
-How long did it take
for me to convince you
this campaign would be worth it?
-I didn't need any convincing.
You had me at OCO.
-They removed Alaska.
-What?
-Alaska's been carved out.
-Section 904.
-Jurisdiction is
limited to crimes
committed in Indian country.
-What's that mean?
-It's a reference to Venetie.
-Supreme Court case.
-In 1998, the Court declared
that Indian country no longer
exists in Alaska.
-OK.
But there are 229 federally
recognized tribes in Alaska.
-And now none of them
have jurisdiction.
-Well, except Metlakatla
-One tribe.
-The other 228 are out.
-Leahy told me they were in.
-Murray said they
wouldn't be left out.
-Someone lied to us.
Murkowski?
-Talk to Begich.
-Unbelievable.
-I have to call Nettie.
-I remember when the Supreme
Court decided Venetie.
I was devastated.
How can the Supreme
Court say there's
no Indian country in Alaska
when I'm standing right
here on the same soil that
my grandparents stood on,
and their grandparents, and
their parents before them?
This has always
been our country.
We are still here.
But according to the United
States Supreme Court,
we don't exist.
My family has always
lived in Tetlin.
I was born in Glen Allen.
And I was almost
put up for adoption
because I was half white.
A Christian family in Wasilla
took me into stay with them
until I was one-year-old,
and then my grandfather
fought to bring
me back to Tetlin.
I am the very first
half from Tetlin,
so in the eyes of the
whites, I can't be native.
They are always looking for
ways to make us disappear.
But I know who I am.
I am Athabascan from
the village of Tetlin,
just like my grandfathers and
their grandfathers before them.
I fish grayling, I hunt Caribou.
I pick berries from
the same field.
I speak the same language,
just like my grandmothers,
my mother, and my relatives.
I have the right
to seek protection
from my tribal government.
I started doing
this work in 1978.
My mother died as a result
of domestic violence,
and her husband
got away with it.
Our representative
in Congress, they
tell us the Supreme
Court has stated legally
there is no Indian
country in Alaska.
But for Native women in
Alaska, Indian country
isn't a legal or even
a academic question.
It's a matter of life and death.
-Murkowski says it
was a drafting error.
-It's definitely an error.
-Then why didn't
you take it out?
-I couldn't
-You're on the committee.
-The state lobbied hard on this.
-What was their position?
-We need to protect
states' rights.
-You meet Alaska's rights.
-Look, I tried to get it out,
but we didn't have agreement.
-We?
-I'm not the only
senator from Alaska.
-I'm not talking to the press.
-Just one comment?
-I said no.
-Senator Murkowski
refused to comment.
-Off the record.
-Fine.
-It was a drafting error.
-Drafting error?
-I didn't know it was there.
-Who put the Indian country
reference to Venetie in there?
-I'm not sure.
-You didn't know the bill
contained a special carve out
for your state?
-Hi, Terri.
-I told you I don't know.
-Nettie.
-Do you plan to fix it?
-Alaska's not included.
-It's not that simple.
-Not included?
-They carved you out.
-Why?
-Alaska's different.
We all know there's no Indian
country left in Alaska.
-Tom.
It's good to see you.
-Congrats on passing the Senate.
-Oh, thank you.
-I hear you're representing
the Eastern Band.
-Yes.
-You forget your from Oklahoma?
-Don't worry.
I still got my twang.
-That's good to hear.
-So how do we get
Leahy-Crapo through the House
with tribal jurisdiction?
-I'm not sure we can.
-Now, that's not what
I wanted to hear.
-Boehner assigned
Cantor to VAWA,
and he's opposed to sovereignty.
-Based on what?
-I think the Constitution.
-Where in the Constitution
does it say tribes
no longer have jurisdiction?
-You don't have to convince me.
You have to convince Cantor.
-So what does he think?
-Well, it's going
to be difficult.
-But he thinks we can do it?
-He's a Congressman,
not a prophet.
-Someone needs sleep.
-Or a Red Bull.
-We need to go where
we're most powerful.
-Our survivors.
-Hard to tell a survivor
she doesn't deserve justice.
-Our stories are powerful.
-Do you think they'd agree?
-To come up here.
-Lisa Brunner would.
-Yes.
-She stood up and spoke out in
'03 when McCain and the Senate
Committee on Indian Affairs
wanted to ignore this issue.
-What about Sarah [? Giles ?]?
-Yes.
-Melissa [? Merrick. ?]
-Diane Millich.
-Her story's very powerful.
-They all are.
-Well, how do we get them here?
-Let me see what I can do.
-At first I wasn't sure.
What would my
family think of me?
-What would my
tribe think of me?
-Why me?
-Shouldn't they be
asking someone else?
-And so when she asked me--
-When Terri said--
-Will you come to DC?
-Will you speak out?
-I really had to think if that
was going to be right for me.
-Would I be
comfortable doing that?
-I was mainly thinking about
protecting my three daughters,
especially my youngest one.
She had no idea
that I'd ever had
to live my life in such a way.
Maybe she's seen these kinds
of things on TV or in movies,
but she didn't know
these things happen
in real life to real people,
to real people that she knows.
-I wanted to protect her.
-Shield her.
-I didn't want to know.
-But I can't shield
her from everything.
-She's already dating.
-She could end up in a
relationship with a young man
who's not enrolled.
-A non-Indian.
-And if he were to
mistreat her, would I
be OK knowing that
I didn't do whatever
I could to help keep her safe?
-No.
So I said yes.
-I agreed to go to DC.
-I agreed to share my story.
-But I was diagnosed
with lupus last week,
and I start chemotherapy
in just a few days.
-Oh, Diane.
I don't know what to say.
-I'm not asking for sympathy.
-If you can't come--
-I'm coming.
I have a serious illness,
but this is important.
-Thank you.
This will make a difference
for all Native women.
-I never told Terri
this, but I didn't
agree to share my story for her,
or even for the other women.
-I did this for my family.
-I did this for my auntie.
-I did this for the
next generation.
I did this for my daughter.
-My daughter was raped
this past summer.
Even though they wore
bandanas, my daughter
recognized their white
skin and their blond hair.
They were doing what I call
hunting on our reservation.
Non-natives know they
can come onto our lands
and rape us with impunity.
My daughter was just in the
wrong place at the wrong time.
She didn't come and
tell me right away.
She washed and she hid it.
That summer, we had another
little girl who was raped,
and nothing was done.
The state did nothing.
So she hung herself.
Our suicide rape
on our reservation
is quite huge, as it is
in all of Indian country.
Still my daughter.
Hearing all of the stories about
this little girl being raped
and her death, she finally
broke and told me what happened,
what happened to her.
My daughter's no better.
They don't go try and party.
We know the dangers
of our environment,
and they know that.
And they know that we're
walking bulls eyes.
We're not just targets.
We're walking bulls eyes.
And so she went out in
the middle of the night
to go find my niece.
She didn't want my niece to get
in trouble for being out late,
because she would have.
And as my daughter
walked down the road,
four white guys in a black
SUV with tan leather interior
were trying to get
her into the vehicle.
And she said no.
She just kept walking.
And this is the
only biggest town
that we have on our reservation,
population maybe 1,400.
And as she's walking, they're
getting more persistent.
She takes off running.
They chase her down.
Two guys, they jumped
out of the vehicle.
They drug her to it.
And as one was driving,
two held her down,
and the fourth one raped her.
And they had bandannas
on over their faces.
And she seen their white
skin, and their blue eyes,
and their blonde hair.
And when they were
done with her,
they threw her
out by the bridge.
As a mom, that more than
took the wind out of me.
That slammed me to the Earth
with such ungodly speed.
And all the measures that I
had tried to protect them,
they didn't it work.
My daughter isn't an
animal that is hunted.
She's a human being.
-Well, if it isn't the
gentleman from Oklahoma.
-I hope I'm not intruding.
-No, no, no.
My 3 o'clock was canceled.
-Sit down.
-Oh, it won't be long.
-VAWA's making me a popular man.
Joe Biden's beating
down my door,
and every woman in the House
wants tell me what she thinks.
-Well, they're for it.
-Well, not all of them.
-You know where I stand.
-I do.
And I wish I could
help you, but I've
got two company chairmen
blocking the Senate bill,
and they won't budge.
-Hastings.
Yeah, well.
-I'll tell you this.
If you can convince Hastings to
vote for tribal jurisdiction,
I'll send it to the floor.
-Well, you and I both know
that will never happen.
-Feel free to come
back to me if it does.
Cantor's bill removes
jurisdiction and replaces it
with federal delegation.
-Well, that won't work.
-But it will pass.
-What if you drafted a bill?
-Me?
Well, you're a popular guy.
People take you seriously.
-Not on Indian issues.
Folks will just say that's
another one of Tom Cole's
Indian bills.
-No, I disagree.
-If I draft the bill,
it'll be dead in the water.
-Well, we don't have
a lot of options here.
It's not like you can ask
a Democrat to draft this.
-Ask Issa.
-Darrell Issa?
-He's Lebanese, not Chickasaw.
It's like, a whole
different tribe.
-Well, seriously, why Issa?
-Well, he's a strong
supporter of the tribes,
and he's chair of the
oversight committee.
-That committee has
nothing to do with this.
-Exactly.
That committee exists purely
to torture the president.
I mean, he's overseeing all
the investigations that look
into Obama, including Benghazi.
So we got ourselves a bona fide,
respected Republican partisan.
If Darrell Issa's name
is first on the bill,
folks will look at.
-OK.
Fine.
Well, could you
just check with him
and see if he'd be
willing to do it?
-I already did.
He said yes.
-Did you have a nice Christmas?
Hard to believe it's 2013.
-Time goes by fast around here.
-I didn't go home
for the holidays.
Stayed here and just
worked straight through.
I figure I'll go home and see
my kids after we win the House.
There'll be plenty of time
for family when we win.
-Cantor refused
to put it to vote.
-What?
-He let the bill expire.
-The bill's dead?
-We'll reintroduce it.
Leahy already has a draft going.
-What good will that do?
-If we can pass it before
the end of January,
it'll be back in the
House by 1st of February.
-We could pass it in the
Senate every year for 50 years.
That won't get
through the House.
-I know you're disappointed.
-I'm going home.
-Deborah.
-I haven't seen my
kids in three months.
-This isn't defeat.
-What do I tell my tribe?
I haven't been to a
council meeting in months,
and now I'm going to
lose my reelection.
-You tell them Patty Murray
says one month from now,
we'll have VAWA 2013
passed in the Senate.
And then what?
You have momentum.
Don't stop now.
-Murray and Leahy
think they could have
a vote by the end of January.
-That's fast.
-Well, they have the votes.
-And we don't.
Tell them to slow down.
-We have momentum.
-90 miles per hour down a dead
end road gets you nowhere.
-We just to convince
Cantor to put it to a vote.
-And he's convinced
it's unconstitutional.
-What's unconstitutional
about recognizing
a tribe's jurisdiction?
-Olifante.
-Are you kidding me?
Have you read Olifante?
-A hundred times.
It still that makes sense to me.
I mean, how do you explain
the Court's decision
that after hundreds of years
of sovereign existence,
a sovereign existence that
predates the United States
Constitution, then all
of the sudden, in 1978,
tribal governments
lost their sovereignty?
Poof.
I guess it just disappeared.
-You know, I used to watch my
dad preside over tribal court.
-My great grandfather was clerk
of our Chickasaw supreme court.
-We prosecuted everyone.
Indian, non-Indian, black,
white, French, Chinese.
It didn't matter.
-If you committed a
crime on the reservation,
the tribe could prosecute you.
-When I was in college,
my sister Rachel,
she was working at the
Casino over in Red Rock.
And this guy, when my
sister finished her shift,
he followed her into the
parking lot, and he raped her.
And when he was done with
her, he left her on the ground
and drove off.
But she saw his license
plate, Joseph Jefferson,
a 34-year-old white
male, chemical engineer,
living in Nichols Hills.
She got his license plate.
-You ask your sister to speak.
People need to hear her story.
-She killed herself.
Six months after the rape
when we figured out our tribe
didn't have jurisdiction
process him,
and he came back to the casino
and started stalking her.
So you're just going
to accept this?
-What do you want me to do?
-Prosecute this man.
You're a judge.
Issue an order.
Have the police arrest him.
-I can't.
-We haven his license plate.
-Dennis.
-We know his name,
where he works.
We know where he lives.
-He's white.
We don't have jurisdiction.
-Olifante?
-Read it.
-I'm not a lawyer.
-I said read it.
-We granted cer--
-Certiorari.
-I don't even know
how to pronounce--
-Read the full sentence.
-We granted certiorari to decide
whether Indian tribal courts
have criminal jurisdiction
over non-Indians.
We decide that they do not.
-What do you think that means?
-It meant I had to
go to law school.
-You read the entire opinion?
-Yeah.
My dad made me.
-Read the last sentence.
-Finally, we are not
unaware of the prevalence
of non-Indian crime on
today's reservations,
which the tribes forcefully
argue requires the ability
to try non-Indians.
But these are
considerations for Congress
to weigh in deciding whether
Indian tribes should be
authorized to try non-Indians.
-What do you think that means?
-Congress has the
constitutional power
to recognize the inherent
sovereignty in Indian tribes.
-You go back, and
you tell Patty Murray
that if she and Leahy can
get through the Senate,
I'll do whatever the hell
it takes to pass the House.
-Leahy's reintroducing
the bill on Monday.
-Murray thinks they'll have
it passed by February 1.
-Isn't that a bit fast?
-She thinks we have momentum.
-But we need buzz and the press.
-I know a reporter at The Times.
-Would he be willing
to write about VAWA?
-She.
-Maybe you could ask her.
-Miss Millich?
Thank you for taking my call.
I'm with The Times.
-Oh, the Aspen Times?
-The New York Times.
-Oh.
-Dennis Whitehawk
gave me your name.
-He's been doing
that a lot lately.
-I'm writing an article
about the tribal jurisdiction
provisions and pose a
reauthorization of VAWA.
Would you be willing
to share your story?
-I was born on the
Southern Ute reservation.
My mother was a
southern Ute, and my dad
was a first generation
Yugoslavian.
When I was 36, I
married a white man,
believing he would treat me
the same way my father treated
my mother.
He moved onto my reservation
and lived with me.
But we weren't married for very
long before he became violent.
The brutality increased
after I left and filed
for a divorce and the
order of protection.
One day, after the
Southern Ute tribal court
awarded my order
of protection, I
was at work when I saw him
pull up in our red truck.
My ex-husband walked inside
our office and told me,
you promised until death do
us part, so death it shall be.
He was armed with a
nine millimeter gun.
If not for my very
brave coworker,
I would not be alive today.
My co-worker prevented by
murdered by pushing me out
of harm's way.
My coworker took the
bullet in his shoulder.
The shooting took place
at a Federal Bureau
of Land Management land
site, where we both worked.
The jurisdictional
issue was so complicated
that after the shooting,
my Southern Ute tribal
police, the Colorado State
patrol, our county sheriffs,
the city police,
the federal agents,
all six agencies
were standing there
with measuring tapes and maps.
-I've got five.
-I've got four.
-This is clearly federal.
-It's at least six inches away.
-Take a look.
The bullet landed on federal.
-And the gun was
fired from state.
-Yeah, but where's the body?
Not in the state.
-It took hours just to
decide who had jurisdiction.
-Look, if you want it, take it.
-Nah.
We don't need feds leftovers.
-This is small
potatoes for feds.
-Southern Ute says
they want to prosecute.
-Yeah, but they don't
have the jurisdiction.
-The district
attorney decided that
the sixth judicial
district of Colorado
would prosecute the case.
-We'd like to offer
a plea agreement.
-What's on the table?
-Attempted voluntary
manslaughter.
-How about aggravated
driving under revocation
for driving without a license?
-He didn't have his license
when he was arrested.
-But he tried to kill someone.
-He's a first time offender.
-He has a history of
domestic violence.
-On the reservation.
-You and I both know
that doesn't count.
Get him for aggravated
driving under revocation,
and you can still look tough.
Show you took a
stand against someone
who put the lives of your
police force in danger.
-No one ever asked
me, the victim,
what I needed to feel safe.
-I'm telling you, aggravated
driving under revocation,
and then we can
all go home happy.
-OK.
-My tribe wanted to prosecute,
but because of Olifante,
they couldn't.
It was like his
attempt to shoot me
and the shooting of my
co-worker didn't happen.
In the end, he was right.
The law couldn't touch him.
He was about the law.
-Thank you.
Thank you for
sharing your story.
-We passed the Senate.
-I knew we would.
-We got 78.
-That's 10 more than last year.
-10 Republicans switched over.
-That's amazing.
-Diane's story in The Times.
-It was powerful.
-That's where those
10 votes came from.
-Huh.
So now we just need
to win in the House.
-Lord, save us.
-I need some caffeine.
-I got coffee.
-Great.
-Terry doesn't need caffeine.
-Oh, well, you can have hers.
-Dennis doesn't drink coffee.
-You don't drink Coffee
-You know that
stuff's bad for you.
[LAUGHING]
-I also brought bagels.
-Dennis doesn't eat bagels.
He only hippie granola stuff.
-They're called Clif bars, and
they're really good for you.
No corn syrup.
No processed ingredients.
-You went to law school
in Northern California.
-All right.
So we need to figure out
the schedule for this week.
-One is setting up a meeting
with the Black Caucus.
-Thank God for Gwen Moore.
-You said you'd
meet with Pelosi?
-I did?
-Yes.
We discussed this.
-OK.
OK.
-I'll be stalking
Cathy McMorris Rodgers.
-Well, what about
Betty McCollum?
-On my list.
-I got McHenry and Denham.
-Paul Cook?
-Talking to him
tomorrow morning.
-Who's checking in Issa?
-That's me.
-Don't forget.
You've got Cole.
-I think you got me.
-Well, whatever you Oklahoma
boys share, its special,
I'm sure.
-So who's got the press?
-I'm with The Washington Post.
-The Los Angeles Times.
-Do you have a minute?
-Yes.
-I read Diane Millich's story.
-It's powerful.
-I'd like to hear yours.
-Why are you here?
-To speak out.
-To share my story.
-To stop the silence.
-Why are you advocating
for jurisdiction?
-One out of three Native women
will be raped in her lifetime.
-60% of Native women will be
assaulted in their lifetime.
-Our women, our children--
-We're not safe.
-What happened?
-My husband tried to shoot me.
-He threatened to drown me.
-My coworker took the
bullet in his shoulder.
-Unbelievable.
-67% of violent crimes
committed against Native women
are committed by non-Native.
-They come to our
reservations because they
know they can harm us.
-They know they are safe.
-They're protected by the law.
-Did you call the police?
-Doesn't help.
-They can't do anything.
-They don't have jurisdiction.
-On your reservation?
-According to the Supreme Court.
-Because I'm a Native woman
living on my tribe's lands.
-The laws won't protect me.
-What kind of message does
that send to our women?
-I know what message
it sent to me.
-I don't understand.
-If the violence is so bad--
-If you aren't safe on
your own reservation--
-If he lives in your home--
-Your home is dangerous--
-Why don't you leave?
-Wouldn't the laws of
the state protect you
if you leave your reservation?
-My great great great great
grandfather was [NON-ENGLISH],
or Standing Wolf.
During the time of the
removal, the soldiers
came to take him and his
family and forced them
to walk the Trail of Tears.
At that time, a white
man named George Hayes
was living with Cherokees.
[NON-ENGLISH] asked Hayes what
he could do to avoid going West
and be allowed to
remain in his homeland.
Hayes advised him to save
up all his food rations,
when he saw the opportunity,
to break away and make
his way back home.
But to be caught escaping meant
severe punishment, or even
death.
One day, several
weeks later, Hayes
was out working
in his yard, when
he saw a small group of people
approaching on the horizon.
It was Standing Wolf, his wife,
and several other Cherokees.
His wife held a
small newborn baby.
Hayes asked Standing Wolf
what the baby's name was.
And Standing Wolf told him
that this new son was named
[NON-ENGLISH], or
Come Back Wolf,
because that was the only
wish in their hearts,
just to come back home.
This is why I and my
grandparents before me
came to be in the mountains
of Western North Carolina.
The Cherokee elders
and wise ones
say that we've
always been there.
We always will be there.
It's believed that we
were given our home there
in those mountains
by the Creator.
Since it was given
to us by the Creator,
only He can take it from us.
So did I ever think
of leaving Cherokee?
-No, not once.
-Never.
-We are still here.
-This is my home.
-I will never leave my home.
-Cathy McMorris Rodgers.
I didn't expect
to see you today.
-I'm on my way to the [? ENC. ?]
-Well, thanks for stopping by.
-Believe me, I'd rather
visiting with you
than sitting in a committee.
-What can I do for you?
-I met with some of the women,
and I heard their stories.
-They're very powerful.
-How do we get the press?
-It's up to Cantor.
-I mean, how do we convince him
to put jurisdiction to vote?
-Well, I've tried.
-He's stubborn as hell.
-I'm sure it'd help if he
heard from you directly.
-Let me see what I can do.
-I think I know what
you're here to discuss.
-Then let's discuss it.
-I'm not putting it to a vote.
-Did you read The New
York Times article?
-Are you kidding me?
I have standards.
-I hate the press
as much as you do.
-You're the one quoting it.
This is about perception.
53% percent of voters in the
last election were women.
Exit polls show that Obama
held the 10 point gender
gap over Romney.
-I've heard the numbers.
-If you refuse to
put VAWA to a vote
now like you did
last year, there
will be consequences
for all of us.
-I'm here because I
don't want to have
this conversation over email.
-We need a vote.
-You think you can just pull
the camel's nose under the tent?
-No one's nose is
going under any tents.
-Oh, they got your nose.
That's for sure.
-What's that supposed to mean?
-You're supposed to be
our guy working with them.
-I think there's been
a misunderstanding.
I'm their guy working with you.
My great great great
grandfather was one of the last
to travel the Chickasaw
Trail of Tears.
He was only 14.
He walked 80 miles.
From 1837 to 1851, the federal
government moved everyone.
We lost everything
except our sovereignty.
After we got to our new
home in Indian territory,
my great great grandfather
served as the clerk
of the Chickasaw Supreme Court.
And after him, my
great grandfather
served as the last
Chickasaw treasurer
before Oklahoma became a state.
And my mother was the
first Native American woman
ever elected to the
state Senate in Oklahoma.
I come from a long line
of Chickasaw leaders--
men and women who
have served not only
their sovereign tribal
government, as I now
serve mine, but also the state
of Oklahoma and the United
States.
I have a lot of respect
for this government,
this sovereign government,
and how it works.
And it works
because people vote.
They vote in the
presidential election,
and they vote in
their state elections.
And here in the House, we vote.
When a bill passes, it passes.
And when it doesn't get
enough votes, it fails.
But no one has to guess whether
the majority of the citizens'
representatives were
for or against a bill
when there's a vote.
That's all we're asking for.
That's all we want.
Please.
Let us have the vote.
-They're voting.
-I remember where I was.
-I remember what I was doing.
-I remember what I was thinking.
-And I will never forget.
-I was on the
floor of the House.
-At my home in Fairfax.
-On my reservation.
-In Cherokee.
-In Alaska.
-Watching CNN.
-C-SPAN.
-Facebook.
-Watching the vote.
Working for votes.
-I couldn't breathe.
-I was so nervous.
-All I could do was pray.
-What's the vote?
-30
-We got 30?
-We need 218.
-We need your vote.
-You got my vote.
-31.
-Thank you.
-62.
-My whole life--
-I dreamed of this.
-85.
-I prayed for this.
-114.
-You got my vote, Tom.
-Thank you.
-115.
-Everything depends on this.
-What if we lose.
-We can't lose.
-Not an option.
-201.
-201?
-Oh, my god.
-I just prayed to Creator.
-215.
-Holy smokes.
-216
-We got this.
-217.
-Is this for real?
-218.
-We did it.
-They're still coming.
More votes.
-235.
-246?
-250.
-285.
-286.
-286?
-286 votes.
-I couldn't believe.
-Unbelievable.
-I had to call Jacks
-Terri texted me.
-I just started texting.
-I started crying.
-I could hardly see who I was
texting, I was crying so hard.
-I had to scream.
-I scared my neighbors.
-I did a victory dance.
-I prayed for my sister.
-It just seemed unreal.
-It felt like a dream.
-It was amazing.
-It was humbling.
-It was a miracle.
-What about Alaska?
-Next time.
I promise.
-Why were we left out?
-Miss Millich?
-This is Diane.
-I'm calling on behalf of Obama.
-Am I getting punked.
-No.
He would like to
invite you to attend
the signing ceremony for VAWA.
-When is it?
-We need you here tomorrow.
-I have to ask my doctor.
-Vice President Biden would
like you to introduce him.
-To who?
-To everyone at the ceremony.
The President and
Vice President would
like to invite you to share
your story with the nation.
-What should I wear?
-Hello, and welcome.
Thank you for joining us today,
for this is very important
event, the signing of
the reauthorization
of Violence Against Women Act.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm very honored
to introduce you
to our first speaker
of the afternoon.
She has traveled
all the way here
from the reservation
in Colorado.
Please welcome Diane Millich.
Good afternoon.
My name is Diane Millich and
I am a citizen of the Southern
Ute Indian tribe.
My mother is known
as Bear Woman.
She is also known as
Arlene Weaver Millich,
and is also a member of the
Southern Ute Indian tribe
in Colorado.
The VAWA being
signed today would
have allowed my tribe to
arrest and prosecute my abuser.
When this act is
signed into law,
VAWA will finally reach
Native women like me.
-And me.
-And my daughter.
-If the Violence Against
Women Act tribal provisions
had existed 15 years ago, my
story would be very different.
-My story would be different.
-My daughter's
will be different.
-This act--
-The tribal
jurisdiction provision--
-It's a step in the
right direction.
-It's an enormous victory.
-But it only covers
domestic violence--
-And protection orders.
-It doesn't cover rape.
-It doesn't cover murder.
-It doesn't cover what
happened to my daughter.
-It protects me.
-It doesn't protect me.
-It excludes 228 federally
recognized tribes in Alaska.
-Why were we cut out?
I read about your
people before I met you.
I have never known
anyone who was Cherokee,
but I read about your
Trail of Tears in 1839.
I read about how the federal
government took your homes
and forced you to walk
thousands of miles.
I read that many
got sick and died.
Everyone keeps
saying, Nettie, we
can't include
Alaska in this bill.
Sorry, Nettie.
We'll protect Alaska
Native women next time.
Sorry, Nettie.
Alaska is different.
What makes us different?
Is it because what happened
to your people in 1839
didn't happen to us until 1959?
Because Congress
passed the Dawes Act
and gave our land to
white settlers in 1887,
but didn't pass [INAUDIBLE] and
gave away our lands until 1971.
Is it because the Supreme Court
took away your jurisdiction
in 1978, but didn't
take ours until it
was decided Venetie in 1998?
Please someone, explain to
me, how are we different?
Because from where I stand, I
see our stories are the same.
-You aren't different.
-We are the same.
-And we stand with you.
-VAWA 2013 is just the start.
-But we have more work to do.
-Until this
government recognizes
our tribe's sovereign authority
to protect all of our Native
women--
-None of us are safe.
-Until this government
recognizes the rights
of our Alaska Native sister--
-None of us are safe.
-VAWA is a miracle.
-A spiritual miracle.
-But it's just the beginning.
-It's just a sliver.
-The first sliver
of a full moon.
[APPLAUSE]
-First, I want to
say thank you to all
of the actors and the director,
and of course, Mary Kathryn.
We sometimes at
the law school have
trouble making
the law come alive
and of people to see its
actual effects in the world.
And here, what we actually
see is the effects
of not having law as well.
And so I just say thank
you to everyone else.
It's an honor for me
to be able to introduce
these three creative and quite
brilliant Native women lawyers.
Maggie McKinley is a Climenko
fellow and a lecturer
of law at Harvard Law School.
She serves as
co-principal investigator
of the Language of
Lobbying Project
at the University of Chicago.
Her scholarship
examines the ways
that minorities participate
in the lawmaking process
in democracies, with a
special focus on lobbying
and petitioning.
And I can say that I think she
single-handedly is creating
an entire new field of law.
And I think it's a very
important and amazing project
that she's working on.
She's conducted a field
study of federal lobbyists
during the campaign
to reauthorize VAWA.
Her mother is a citizen
of Fond du Lac band
of Minnesota Ojibwe,
and her father
is Irish Catholic
from the Bronx.
Angela Riley is currently the
Oneida Indian Nation Visiting
Professor of Law at
Harvard Law School.
This semester, she's a professor
of law at UCLA School of Law,
as well as the director of
UCLA's joint program in law
and American Indian studies.
Her research focuses on issues
related to indigenous peoples
rights, with a particular
emphasis on cultural property
and native governance.
I should say good
native governance, which
is the name of her article.
In 2003, she became the first
woman and the youngest justice
of the supreme court of the
citizen of the Potawatomi
Nation of Oklahoma.
2010, she was elected
as Chief Justice.
She now serves as co-chair for
the United Nations Indigenous
Peoples Partnership
Policy Board,
and is an evidentiary hearing
officer for the Morongo
Band of Mission Indians.
And have to say,
she was my student,
and I feel a particular
pride in her accomplishments.
There's a Jewish term,
which is not [NON-ENGLISH],
which is a term that parents
use about their children.
It means this sort
of unmitigated joy
that you get in talking
about your children.
So I feel [NON-ENGLISH]
for Angela.
And finally, Mary
Kathryn Nagle, who I've
just met today for
the first time.
Mary Kathryn's obviously an
accomplished Native playwright
and lawyer.
She's the author of the
play that we just saw.
In addition to practicing
and publishing--
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you.
-Here, here.
-In addition to practicing and
publishing academic articles
on Indian law, Mary
Katheryn has begun a project
of telling the stories of
Indian country relating
to law and policy.
She's using art as a
way to bring to people
the reality of the legal
system and the situation
of Indian nations in
the United States,
and especially Native women.
In addition to Sliver
of a Full Moon,
she has documented the struggle
of the Sac and Fox Nation
to reclaim the
body of Jim Thorpe.
And I didn't know
that she created
a reenactment of the first
federal court decision
to declare Natives as
persons under federal law.
That's kind of amazing.
She's a citizen of the
Cherokee Nation of Oklahoma,
and a very creative advocate
on behalf of Indian country,
obviously.
And it's a great honor for me
to be able to introduce her.
[APPLAUSE]
-I just want to begin with a
few questions for this panel.
And then, I'd like to turn the
active posing questions over
to the audience, so we can
get some wider discussion
going on there.
After listening to this
reading-- thank you again--
at some level, there
are some obvious ways
to go with this
question But let me just
pose it just most
frankly so you can speak
to the issues, all of you.
Where do we go from here?
Does the story of Sliver tell
us anything about what changes
are necessary in statute,
in jurisprudence,
in constitution-making,
or amendment-making
to make tribal
sovereignty a reality,
the reality that it should be.
And what are some of those
changes, and not simply
identifying those, what are
strategies to make them happen?
I'd like the three of you to
potentially reflect on that.
-Could I offer a quick
point of clarification.
Because this is something
in the play but I thought
was really powerful,
but the language
wasn't always as precise
as lawyers love it to be.
So I just want to--
so as far as-- I know.
I'm sorry.
So as far as making
sovereignty a reality,
I don't believe that
one government can
tell another government
what sovereignty is,
or create that
government's sovereignty.
I think sovereignty exists
in Indian country separate
from the federal government and
whatever the federal government
recognizes.
So the distinction that I'd like
to make in this conversation
that I offer to the panel-- and
I hope that we can agree on--
is that the federal government
recognizes tribal sovereignty.
It does not create it,
nor does it get rid of it.
[APPLAUSE]
-Angela?
Or Mary Kathryn?
-Sure.
Thank you.
Maggie, I think we're
on the same wavelength.
So yeah, I think it's
an interesting question.
I just had a couple
of points to raise.
And then I really want to
hear more from everyone else,
and I want to say thank you to
everyone for inviting me here,
and for this
wonderful experience.
And of course, for the
performers and survivors
for presenting.
Thank you.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
The play raises for me
a few critical points.
The first one is one
that Maggie already made.
And that is that tribal
sovereignty really
is a reality.
Our sovereignty is inherent.
We have it.
We do exercise it.
And we live it.
We have had moments
in time where
it has been curbed by
either the US Supreme Court
or by the Congress.
And things like the
reauthorization of VAWA
did not give us sovereignty.
It limited a restriction
on our inherent sovereignty
that was already there.
In terms of thinking about
other places to go with VAWA,
some of these things are
touched on in the play.
And I've been
doing some research
around the way the cases
have been playing out
at the tribal level and
in the tribal courts.
And so some of the really
obvious places for expansions
and to really make the law
have the kind of impact
that it needs to have
to really make families
safe on reservations--
so one critical place is
to extend it to child abuse.
In many of these
instances, children
were involved, in cases that
all three tribes that prosecuted
defendants during the
pilot project period.
Children were involved in
numerous of those cases.
The crimes against the children
can't be prosecuted under VAWA,
so they have to be referred
to another sovereign.
Sometimes they get prosecuted,
sometimes they don't.
So that's one obvious
place for extension.
But as you heard in the play,
there are also a lot of things
that VAWA doesn't
apply to, including
situations involving strangers.
There has to be
a particular kind
of relationship
with the defendant
and the reservation
or the victim.
And so it limits the kind
of stranger situations
we see, and that
have particularly
been going on in some of
the Northern Plains areas
with the increase in extractive
industry and non-Indians
coming onto reservations
committing crimes
against Native
women, but not having
enough of a nexus to be
prosecuted under the statute.
And the final thing, I think,
that's just really important
is to educate people
more about tribal courts.
During the pilot
project period, there
were three tribes that
prosecuted defendants
under VAWA.
There were 26 total cases.
Of those cases, one went
all the way to a jury trial.
And that defendant had a
jury panel of all Indians,
except for one person
who was non-Indian.
And that non-Indian defendant,
the first and only person to be
prosecuted and tried all the
way to a jury since Olifante
in 1978, and was acquitted.
He wasn't convicted.
And I think many people
feel that this is-- whatever
the infirmities
may or may not have
been in that particular
case, it just demonstrates,
for one thing, that non-Indians
can and do get fair treatment
in tribal courts.
Tribal courts want to protect
the rights of defendants
just like state courts, and
just like federal courts do.
And the other thing that
sort of was interesting
is that all the people that
were prosecuted during the pilot
project period, not one of them
filed a writ of habeas corpus.
So they all had the opportunity
to go to the federal court
and say, my rights are being
violated in tribal court.
I want to be tried
elsewhere, or I
want to challenge the
tribe's authority over me.
And none of them did, and
none of them wanted to.
I've spoken with people who had
contact with those defendants,
and they were really
happy with their treatment
in tribal court, which
they felt was actually
much more respectful and fair
than a lot of the treatment
they'd had outside
of tribal courts.
So those are I think
the main points
I wanted to just emphasize,
and then I'll turn it over
to my co-panelists.
-Sure.
Well, you've heard a
lot from me tonight.
And I have a lot to say.
But I think kind of adding to
what Angela and Maggie have
said, which are some really
excellent points, just
to add something new to
the conversation that
hasn't already been said, I
would just point to the fact
that this play does talk
about this huge victory we
had in 2013, which
is really amazing.
And as Maggie points
out, our tribes
were sovereign before 1492.
They were sovereign
after 1776, after 1887.
They're still sovereign today.
We don't have to
ask for sovereignty.
We inherently have it.
And yet we keep having to defend
it in the United States Supreme
Court.
And why is that?
And there's a huge case
to look to right now.
And it's a bit alarming that we
can be celebrating this victory
in 2013 in VAWA from
Congress, and that we
have a United
States President who
recognizes that our tribes are
sovereign and respects that,
and on December 7, our
United States Supreme Court
will hear a case
that really goes
to the heart of tribal
sovereignty in the Dollar
General case.
And I think it's a
case that highlights
a lot of the issues that
have been discussed tonight.
Because in that case-- I'll
try to briefly summarize
the facts-- Dollar
General operates a store
on tribal trust
lands in Mississippi,
on the reservation
of the Mississippi
Band of Choctaw Indians.
And they entered into a
contractual arrangement
with the tribe, whereby
they lease their lands,
and they also agreed
in the contract
to subject themselves
to tribal jurisdiction.
Well, they also agreed to
participate in a tribal youth
employment program.
And during the course of an
employee, a summer intern
from the tribe, a
13-year-old boy,
the non-Indian
supervisor in the store
sexually assaulted the
tribal youth two times.
And now we know because
of Olifante in 1978,
his tribe cannot
prosecute that crime.
And also despite the fact of
the reauthorization in 2013
and the restoration
of jurisdiction,
there's no
jurisdiction for crimes
committed against our children.
And so the tribe has no
criminal jurisdiction,
according to the Supreme
Court, to prosecute this crime.
The federal government
hasn't done anything.
Of course, they could.
Under the framework the
Supreme Court has created,
they could prosecute,
and they have not.
And so the only thing
the tribe can offer
is civil court jurisdiction,
which is something
that a lot of other sovereigns,
like our state and federal
sovereigns, also offer.
And the idea being that if
you are abused and battered,
you can go into a civil
court and file a tort
lawsuit against the
individual, the entity, that
battered you or hurt you.
And in this case, the
parents of the youth
have filed a lawsuit
in tribal court
saying, please, Dollar
General, we think
you need to pay for
our child's pain
and suffering because our
child was abused on your watch
at your store by your employee,
and you didn't stop it.
And that's a very
common theory of law
in terms of negligent
supervision of your employee
when there's been
a sexual assault.
And Dollar General's
real argument
has been to date, and it hasn't
progressed to the [? merits, ?]
because their only
argument has been,
the tribal court doesn't
have jurisdiction over us.
We're not Indian.
And it's going all the way up
to the United States Supreme
Court.
On December 7, the Supreme
Court will hear the arguments.
And if you read
their brief, it's
like Olifante all over again.
First of all, they
cite Olifante, I think,
like I lost count,
maybe 50 times.
And they are asking for nothing
less than the Supreme Court.
It's kind of like they're
saying, Supreme Court,
you did it in Olifante.
You know how to do it.
You already took away their
criminal jurisdiction.
Now take away their civil.
And what's really
inherent in their message
is that tribal
courts are inferior.
Which as Angela pointed
out, they're simply not.
They're simply not.
And so I think it's alarming
that we can be making progress
on certain fronts,
and that we're
threatened with retrogression
on other fronts.
And so I just wanted
to draw that out
as another point
of conversation.
-Just to build a bit on
Mary Kathryn's point.
Something that is
this interesting,
or a little bit sad,
but still interesting,
is that Indian country has
not had a whole lot of success
in the Supreme Court
for the last 40 years.
And that's saying
it's very lightly.
There hasn't been a
whole lot of successes,
and Olifante was issued
before I was born.
And so for my lifetime, we
have not seen many successes
anywhere, actually.
Not even in the Congress.
And so I think what
Sliver captures
and what the VAWA
reauthorization can communicate
on what happens
next is first, it
is hope that
something can be done
for a whole generation
of women and Natives
who have not seen anything
go their way with respect
to the federal government.
And so that's one thing.
It tells us that possible
is possible for once.
It also gives us an avenue
for enacting that change.
So the mechanism by which this
recognition of tribal court
jurisdiction happened
was through the Congress.
It was through lobbying.
It was through
legislative advocacy.
It was not true
through litigation
in the courts, which is lost
and lost and lost and lost.
And in this area, I think,
not just understanding
the law is helpful, but
understanding those mechanisms,
so we can start to open them
for future progressive work.
Because what's happened
here is we've lucked out,
because VAWA was passing
through the Congress,
to be able to latch onto it.
This is an institution
that has passed fewer laws
and done fewer things,
and it's completely
paralyzed in so many ways.
And if this is our
only avenue for change,
not only do we need to
think about Indian country,
we also need to think
about the Congress,
and how we can make
that a place to where
our voices will be
heard, and real change
can make it through.
Not just a sliver, but
real statutory change.
Real legislative change
that can make our courts--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
-Joe, would you like to--
-Yeah.
I wanted to just say that one
of the problems that we see
is that the Supreme
Court issues rulings,
and they just assume
that Congress will fix
whatever problems they create.
And I agree with what
Maggie just said.
We hope that we can get
Congress to do things.
But realistically,
it's very hard
to get Congress to do things.
And the Supreme Court sort
of puts it off on Congress,
you fix it.
The Congress puts it off
on the Court and says,
you tell us what
tribal sovereignty is,
and if there's no
tribal sovereignty,
well, that's not our problem.
And they're both sort of
putting responsibility
on someone else, not themselves.
And this problem exists
in those situations
where the law that was
passed, the VAWA 2013,
did a lot of good things.
But there are a lot
of Indian nations
that are not going to get
jurisdiction under that law
because there are
certain requirements
to get jurisdiction.
And for women in
those nations, what
they need, if it's not going
to happen that there'll
be jurisdiction, what
they need is better law
enforcement by the federal
government, and in some cases,
by the state governments,
depending on the local--
there are several states
where the states do their law
enforcement.
And everyone is refusing
to take responsibility.
And this is one of the
things that, to me, is why
works of art are so crucial.
Because it's very easy
for people to say,
it's not my problem.
Someone else should
take care of it.
And the federal prosecutors
say we don't have enough money.
We're not close.
We're not near where
their crimes are.
We just don't have
enough resources.
It's not the thing that
we're going to focus on.
And they're sort of saying,
it's the Congress's fault.
And the result of all of
this is that you wind up
having people that
are left vulnerable.
And it's works of art,
I think, that actually
can help us actually understand
the significance of the failure
of people who should
take responsibility
to take responsibility.
-Thank you.
-I just want to--
one more question
to sort of extend
upon that theme
before we go to the audience,
which is that as Professor
Singer just sort of put it,
if you don't mind I give it
this reading, that
basically this issue
has become something
of a hot potato passed
back and forth between
Congress and the Courts.
And Sliver does give us
hope in that respect.
And one of the
things that I thought
was so powerful about it
was going back and forth
between the stories of
survivors and the nitty gritty
of the legislative process.
And I don't have a stopwatch
there, but a lot of this
takes place in Washington,
where these talks are occurring.
And so, given that Congress
needs to be persuaded,
needs to be nudged, needs
to be shoved, what can we
do, the Academy, artists, those
who are the audience for Sliver
as well as the actors
for it, to bring
about pressure on Congress?
I get some lessons.
We get some lessons.
The role of the media.
The role of the stories.
My guess is there may be others.
And I'd like to hear the panel,
and Mary Kathryn and Maggie,
people who study
lobbying and petitioning
to think about that.
What needs to be
done politically?
-Well, I mean, I would
just say, in reflecting
on this play and the
political process,
is that I was not-- as
a playwright coming in,
I was a little bit coming
in from the outside.
I was not a leader in
the movement itself.
And actually, at
the very last minute
when they were really struggling
to get through the House,
I think lot of leaders
in the movement
realized the power
of the stories,
and how the women who
were coming forward
as survivors to
tell their stories
in Congressional hearings in
the press and in the media
was actually moving the dial.
And that, actually,
I think a lot
of people in the movement
across the board,
not just tribal leaders
and Native women,
would agree and would
tell you that VAWA
got reauthorized in 2013
because Native women stood
up and spoke.
That all the other--
[APPLAUSE]
-All the other
constituencies were stuck.
And when Diane Millich, who--
I mean, I am not Diane Millich.
Let's make that clear.
So when she tells her story,
her story so powerful.
It is so much more
powerful when she tells it.
And I was very
heartbroken that she
got stuck in Denver
because of a blizzard.
But when Lisa Brunner
tells her story,
when Billie Jo tells her story,
there is a power in that.
And I think that's what
makes this play powerful.
That's what made the
political process powerful.
And I think it's a huge
testament to the fact
that I think the
biggest victory we've
had legally for Indian nations
in the history of the United
States came from a movement
that was created and propelled
forward by Native women
who told their stories.
And I think that
really says a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
-Maggie or Angela?
-So I was able to see the
discussions behind the scene
when the statute was
drafted and passed.
And it was an incredibly
intense experience for me,
because it didn't
looked like it was going
to make it many, many times.
But it was also
incredibly inspiring,
because I got to see that
behind the scenes in Congress,
it's not just power that counts.
They actually do have
discussions about the law
and what the Constitution
means, and they
deliberate over these questions.
And the real question
was whether or not
this was constitutional
after Olifante.
There were real concerns.
So to the extent that legal
scholars, and lawyers,
and academics, and
activists could get in there
and explain the law to
Congress quickly in a way
that they could understand,
it actually moved the process
forward exponentially.
So I know we think that
it's just mudslinging
and power all the way down, but
it's not necessarily the case.
There actually is
a space for reason,
and therefore, a
space for advocacy.
Not just with the stories
of survivors, which I think
are so integral
and so important,
but also about discussions of
the law and the Constitution.
-And just to add to that,
just one other thing
that I think we saw with
the reauthorization of VAWA,
and that I think it's going to
be really critical to us going
forward is, we're a tiny
percentage of the population.
I mean, depending
on whether you go
by enrollment or
self-identification,
we're 1% to 2% of
the US population.
By almost every
marker in the country,
we tend to be the poorest,
the most isolated,
have the least
opportunity, et cetera,
so we don't have access
to a lot of power,
and we don't have access
to a lot of money.
But one thing that
we saw with VAWA
is that we have to make friends.
There has to be coalition
politics going on.
We have to find people
whose interests are aligned
with ours in ways that
are commonsensical
and go to people's basic sense
of fairness, and justice,
and what is right, as I
think the people tonight,
the performers,
the men and women,
have really demonstrated.
And I think being
able to speak to that
and to find friends
and find allies outside
of Indian country is really
critical to getting legislation
passed of this kind.
-Can I just add
one more comment?
-Please.
-Because I feel like we always
say, what is the solution?
How do we make this change?
And I think this is a
part of the solution.
I think what we are doing
here tonight is actually
pretty revolutionary.
Because I'm wearing
this lawyers hat,
but I'm also wearing
my playwright's hat.
And as a playwright, I look
at this country culturally,
which we know informs our laws.
And we still live
in a country where
if you go to the
American theater,
you're much more likely to
see a non-Native performing
red face on stage than an actual
Native body, a Native person,
on stage performing
Native identity.
And you have to ask
yourself, why is that?
And do you know any theater,
any professional theater
in the United States right
now, producing a play
by a Native playwright?
I can tell you
several theaters that
have in the last several
years or will soon
produce a play by a
non-Native playwright that
puts red face on stage.
And when you think about
what this play is doing
by putting actual Native people
on stage to tell their stories,
that's a pretty
revolutionary act.
And when you look at the
Supreme Court's jurisprudence,
I think sometimes when we start
talking about it in Olifante,
they're like, well, how
could the Supreme Court strip
tribes of their jurisdiction?
When you're living in a country
where you have no voice,
the Court responds to that.
The Court is a political, but it
is also a cultural institution.
And so, I do think that
art is a very, very, very
important part of the solution.
-Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-We had a play, and
we have an audience,
and I note here that at 20
after 8:00 on a Thursday night,
we have an audience that
has, as far as I can tell,
well over 100 members
still left in it.
And I want to thank
everybody for coming.
And now, we'd like to
turn the possibility
for opposing questions to
this panel over to you.
There is a stand and a
microphone in the center aisle.
And if you would like to
just get up and line up
behind that microphone to
ask a question, any question,
to this panel or offer some
thoughtful remarks, please
do so.
Keep in mind that we
have about 20-25 minutes
left in the evening, so
that you don't take up
so much time that time is not
remaining to those behind you.
Go ahead.
-Hi.
A pleasure to be
here this evening.
Thank you so much for
having this open discussion
and play reading.
Beautiful, beautiful work.
Congratulations.
I am curious and a
little questioning,
because I didn't quite see the
connection between the Cherokee
and the Alaska nation.
And I know part of the
work that is done here
is reflecting a lot of
the Cherokee struggle.
So maybe some elucidation on
that would be really great.
-Sure I'm happy to give that.
And is Nettie still here?
-She left?
-OK.
-So from my point of view--
and I'm not Alaskan native.
And unfortunately,
Nettie has left,
but we're very thankful
that she could be here
with us, because she
came a very long way.
And if you can imagine
traveling from Alaska
all the way here for this,
it was at least 30 hours
of traveling.
And now she's about
to make 30 hours back.
But I think that a lot of
the discussions around Alaska
politically, and
in terms of sort
of the-- everything in
Congress gets shortened,
and so the conversation
gets a bit truncated.
But what people say is,
well, Alaska's different.
And a lot of times when I talk
to other federal Indian lawyers
who are working
in the Lower 48--
because I'm a little bit
new on the scene too.
I'm like, how do we have
this legal framework?
Like how is it that we just
seem to have Alaska excluded,
and we're not
fighting this harder?
And a lot of people will say,
well, Alaska's just different.
And so I started talking to
a lot of women in Alaska,
and trying to figure out,
why is Alaska different?
And the only thing
we could figure out
is-- because it's not that
they don't have tribes.
They have 229 federally
recognized tribes.
They have more
tribes than Oklahoma.
So it's not because
they don't have tribes.
It's not because they
don't have Native people.
They have their
ancestral homelands,
just like we have ours.
And when you look at
it, I think the point
of making that connection
is that-- I think
it's really easy for us
in this country today
to look at what happened to
my nation, Cherokee Nation,
in 1839, and say wow, that
Trail of Tears was awful.
And Andrew Jackson
shouldn't have done that.
And I can sit here today and
say he shouldn't have done that.
But what do we do when we're
still doing that in Alaska?
How do we live
with ourselves when
we're actually just still
doing the exact same thing?
And when you look at Alaska,
it's the exact repetition.
We had Trails of Tears and
Indian removal in the 1830s
up through the 1880s here.
Same thing happened in Alaska.
They came in.
Everyone was living
where they had
lived for thousands of years.
And the government said,
you've got to move here.
If you don't send your
kids to this school,
we're going to put you in jail.
And in 1887, Congress
passed the Dawes Act,
and basically broke up a
lot of tribal reservations
and distributed tribal lands
to non-Indian settlers.
Congress did the same
thing to Alaska in 1971.
And then when you
think about Olifante,
the Supreme Court in
1978 said, you guys
don't have jurisdiction anymore.
In 1998, the Supreme
Court said, there's
no Indian country
left in Alaska.
So to me, they're
exactly the same.
But law is just a set of rules
that at the end of the day,
nine people decide, or Congress
when they come in and maybe fix
what nine people decided.
So these are all frameworks
that we've created,
and that it's really a question.
How is Alaska different?
Because it really
isn't, I think.
-One quick note.
I'd like to mention
Hawaii, because that's also
treated as different.
In Hawaii, it's not
treated as Indian country.
There is no tribal sovereignty.
And you have native
peoples who are still
fighting every day
to have recognition
in the first instance.
And so, I think this
patchwork that we have,
as we've seen the
patchwork of jurisdiction
does not serve
Indian women well,
the patchwork of
treatment of tribes
from Alaska, to Hawaii,
to the 50 states,
the complexity is alone a cost.
It is alone a problem
that we need to remedy.
-I just want to
mention Massachusetts.
The [INAUDIBLE] tribe
just lost a case recently
because the history of the
federal recognition of tribes
in Massachusetts is
very different from what
it is in other places.
So I think to some
extent, we actually
would like to have the
relation to the United States
and the tribes be
different from each tribe,
because each tribe
has the ability
to create a relationship
which suits it.
On the other hand, some
of these differences
are nothing less
than discriminatory,
because they are denying
certain of the Indian nations
basic rights and
sovereign powers that
are given to others without
adequate reason other
than we did it in 1978.
Which is not good
reason for some
of these different treatments.
-Thanks, Joe.
Question?
-Hi.
My name is Christopher
[? Helium. ?]
I'm actually a student in
Professor Riley's Federal
Indian Law class.
I wanted to say first off
that that was amazing.
And I'm very impressed
at the ability
of that to boil down a very
complicated legal issue
into a way that's
very digestible.
So I thought that
was very impressive.
My question is actually somewhat
similar to the last question
about Alaska.
I was sort of unclear as to why
the state doesn't enforce laws
in Alaska.
I understand that in a lot of
ways, the situation in Alaska
is very similar.
But the legal situation,
as we learned in class,
is really different in
Alaska, as you mentioned.
And I'm just wondering what
it's like on the ground there.
-Once again, I wish
Nettie was here.
But she's not, so I'll
take this question.
So you know for a long time,
the Alaska attorney general--
once again, going back
to the very basic point,
our tribes are sovereign.
We don't need the
federal government
to tell us that we're sovereign.
At the same time, we live
in the reality of 2015.
And for a long time, the state
attorney general in Alaska
had refused to enforce tribal
court protection orders.
And so if you can imagine, a
lot of Native women in Alaska,
where they suffer the highest
rates of domestic violence
in the United States, could
go to their tribal court,
get at protection order,
and then the state
would refuse to enforce it.
So basically, if
you went anywhere
outside your little
community, you were not safe.
No law enforcement
would protect you.
Now, why would the state refuse
to enforce protection orders?
Honestly, you know, I
could make some guesses,
but they never really decided
to announce their reasoning.
So they did recently--
the attorney general
within the last several
months did come out
with a new opinion
saying they will now
enforce tribal court
issued protection orders.
I think they received
a few messages
from the federal
government about how
it was in violation
of federal law
to not enforce those
protection orders.
So I think they received
some encouragement
to bring them into compliance.
But I think that for
a lot of states--
so I can kind of
generalize a little bit,
because I live in Oklahoma.
And in this Dollar General
case that I was talking about,
our attorney general,
Attorney General Pruitt,
filed an amicus brief on
the side of Dollar General,
arguing that, oh, yeah, yeah,
by the way, tribes in Oklahoma
also don't have civil
jurisdiction over non-Indians.
Can you imagine the chaos
that would happen if they did?
And he listed like a
parade of horribles,
like if a non-Indian drove
into a casino parking lot
and didn't realize he
was on tribal trust land,
and then all of a sudden could
be brought into tribal court
for doing something
awful to someone.
Oh, my gosh.
And they list all these
parade of horribles.
Well, you have to wonder,
why is the AG fighting
tribal civil
jurisdiction so hard?
Why does the Alaska
AG care so much
about not enforcing tribal
court protection orders?
And I think-- this
is just purely
my thought, because I don't
work for a state government.
But I think that at
the end of the day,
the rights of our
Native women get
sacrificed by state governments
who want tribal lands.
Want the resources, the oil, the
money, the taxes, the revenues.
And that's been happening, as
we say in the play, since 1492.
So the idea being, I think,
for state governments that
don't want the resources
and the minerals
and whatever's on the
land within a reservation
to be taken away
from them, they don't
want any kind of precedent
that actually recognizes
tribal sovereignty, because
that might limit their ability
somewhere down the road
to extract something
that could make money.
And so that's where you
see Native women become
the sacrifice for those kinds
of profits, if that makes sense.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you.
Next question.
-Hello. [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
My name's [? Farina ?] King, and
I'm a Native American History
PhD Candidate from
Arizona State University,
currently a visiting scholar
at Dartmouth College.
And I'm so grateful that--
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, thanks.
I am so grateful to have
this opportunity to see this.
It's so powerful.
And I just had to cover my
mouth and think of puppies
not to ball.
Because my existence is
based off of a relationship
that probably was rape.
We don't know because
of the silences.
Because my grandfather was
a parentless Navajo man
who went to become
a medicine man.
But you know, I'm doing
my family history,
and piecing together
a story of his mother
who worked for a trader, and he
slept with several Navajo women
and had several
children with them.
Anyway, so for me, I've
often thought about this,
and how my father, you
know, that doesn't exist.
He's Navajo.
Full Navajo.
That's not a part of his story.
His father didn't speak English.
This is a part of it.
And not only that, but also
the stories of my family,
and that almost every woman
in my family on my Navajo side
has faced abuse,
sexual, physical.
That my father saw his mother
beat to the ground, my grandma.
And so this was really strong
for me, and thank you so much.
I have two quick questions.
One is, a lot of abuse
that I hear about as well
is actually done by Native men.
And I found it really
amazing in the story
how you featured the men
supporting the women here.
But how does that affect
this movement as well,
of the abuse done by Native men.
And then secondly,
there's a conversation
about-- I heard some
Native American lawyer
activist saying we
need to stop talking
on moral terms in
these cases and push
more talking about economics.
And so how does economic
terms affect this movement
and these battles
as well, and also
those types of contestations?
[NON-ENGLISH] Thank you.
-Thank you.
I just wanted to take a
crack at the first question,
and then turn it over.
So I think,
absolutely, depending
on the demographics of a
particular reservation, some
as you know are heavily
allotted and have
a lot of non-Indians
living there.
Some have a lot of non-Indians
who come onto the reservation
either to live and work,
or for other reasons.
So your reservation
demographics can
have a lot to do with what
the makeup is, and therefore,
who enters into relationships,
and therefore where
domestic violence really rests.
So there's no question
that on some reservations,
a significant part of
the domestic violence
is occurring in couples were
both partners are Indian.
Where the perpetrator's Indian
and the victim is Indian.
And one of the things that,
just looking at the way
that I think tribes have
approached this-- so tribes do
have criminal jurisdiction over
Indians on the reservation.
And so one of the things
that's been really critical
is consistent standard set
forms of funding so that tribes
can implement the kinds of
criminal justice systems
that they need, so
that they can basically
police their own communities
and hold people accountable.
And part of that, really, is
that the Indian Law and Order
Commission out of the
Tribal Law and Order Act
did an amazing exhaustive
report about criminal justice
in Indian country.
And one of the things
that they found
was that even if a prosecution
in a tribal court parallels,
or in many ways,
is similar to what
would happen in a federal
court, just the legitimacy
of having the tribe being
able to police and enforce
its own laws on the reservation
among its own people
increases the buy in of
the people to the system.
Many Native people don't
find outside criminal justice
systems to be legitimate,
because for so long
they've caused us harm.
They haven't worked
to our advantage.
to protect as.
They work to come
and take people away.
So people don't really trust it.
And so one of the
things that I think
is just, in my own research,
one of the critical components,
is investing in tribal
justice systems,
supporting them, consistent
forms of funding,
empowering tribes to engage
in criminal justice activities
themselves on the reservation.
And when you do that, you do
actually see better outcomes.
It hasn't been studied very
extensively, but what we do see
is there are better
outcomes when that happens.
So there's a big
push to really try
to channel some of
those funds away
from federal or
state governments
and back into
tribal governments,
partially for that purpose.
-With respect to the
economic argument,
I'll just answer
very, very quickly.
You know, I haven't
seen it work.
Not with Congress.
Not in the way this did.
And I think it also
doesn't empower
communities, our
communities, in the same way
to talk about economics.
Generally, economists do that,
whereas this is something
that folks can relate to.
I think that there
are ways to talk
about the stability of tribal
governments and economics,
and that's something that was
there a major accomplishment
of the Harvard
Project, to understand
that our problem with
economics in Indian country
is a problem of governance,
of the inability
of tribal governments to not
only know what they're supposed
to be doing, but also to
govern within the limits,
extreme limits,
that have been set
on them by the
federal government.
So I think that there
are arguments there,
but as you've seen
today, it's hard to have
a play about economics
in the same way.
-That'll be my next play.
-She can pull it off, if anyone.
-Next.
-Hi.
My name is Christopher
[? Lukasic. ?]
I'm an undergraduate student at
the University of Massachusetts
at Amherst.
So Professor Riley, you talked
about how Native people are not
really trusting of the
criminal justice system.
And my question basically is,
did the rate protective orders
for Native women increase
after the reauthorization?
And if so, actually,
I'll leave it at that.
I have a second question,
but I'll hold that off.
-So after VAWA, were there
more protection orders?
Is that the question?
-Yeah.
-I don't know that precisely.
I mean, what we do
know is that there
were 26 non-Indians prosecuted
for domestic violence.
Some of those also, not all
of them, but some of those
also involved the violation
of a protection order,
some which were tribal,
and some which were
issued by other sovereigns.
So it certainly was
a feature of that.
And really crimes that
probably would have gone
unprosecuted otherwise.
One other thing that
was really interesting,
and also goes to the
protection order issue,
is that if you look at
the assessment of one
of the tribes that had the
most prosecutions in the Pilot
Project period, it was
[INAUDIBLE] in Arizona.
And they calculate--
and I'm going
to give you the statistic,
and maybe a little off.
But it's something around
that of the 18 cases
they had involving
15 defendants,
those defendants had close
to 100 contacts with police
prior to the arrest that
led to their prosecution.
But many times,
the tribal police
were acting as a peace
officer in those instances,
and then the tribe
didn't have jurisdiction,
and then nothing happened.
And then there's
another contact.
And then nothing happened.
Not all of the contacts
were criminal in nature.
They could have been a variety
of different kinds of contexts.
But almost 100 contacts
of those defendants.
And certainly, many of
them involved violations
of protection orders.
So I don't know exactly if
the number has increased,
but there's clear
that there is crime
happening in Indian
country by non-Indians.
-And my second
question is, what type
of culturally appropriate
prevention programs
need to be implemented
to actually prevent
violence against Native women?
-Well, I think there's a whole
range of different programs.
And the VAWA that
got reauthorized
in 2013, as I said
earlier, was the result
of the huge movement.
And a lot of the women who
were involved in the movement
are involved in their
own communities,
and are involved in this work.
And so a lot of tribes
have tribal programs
that are led by Native women
in those communities that
are leading the way.
And actually, Lisa Brunner
sitting right here,
is a really great example.
And so I would encourage
anyone to talk to her
about the efforts
that she's undertaken
to do a lot of that work.
And I will just give
a quick shout out
to also one of my good
friends, is Gregory Gray Cloud
And he's working at
Rosebud right now,
and he has a group
called Wica Agli.
And that's spelled W-I-C-A, new
word, A-G-L-I. So look it up.
They're doing amazing work.
The whole theory of that
group is it's led by men,
and it's this idea that the way
to stop violence against women
is to educate the men.
And that it's actually
a man's responsibility.
[APPLAUSE]
And what's so beautiful
about the work
that they're doing is that the
tribal court there in Rosebud
has agreed, has like basically
taken them under on a contract.
And so anyone who's convicted
of a domestic violence
crime in Rosebud
tribal court will then
go through the program with
Wica Agli that he runs.
And it's a
culturally-based program
because it's not
within Lakota culture
to treat women that
way, to abuse women.
So it's about
restoring the culture,
and restoring the value women.
Because in our tribal
cultures-- I dont'
want to speak too broadly.
I mean, I've never encountered
a tribal culture that didn't
practice respecting women.
Yes.
So I think, in terms of the
most culturally appropriate
best programs are, when
our men stand up and say
it's my job to work with
other men in our community
and to teach them
how to treat women.
Now unfortunately, because of
all the jurisdictional issues,
we're not really in a place
where a program like that
works with non-Indians.
Because even though we have the
restored jurisdiction in VAWA,
it's very westernized, and it's
imposing a very Westernized
system.
And so things we want
to do outside of that,
we have to get creative.
-I think just this one follow up
there's nothing more culturally
appropriate them local
control and allowing
tried to self-govern, and
to set their own programs,
and to protect their own
people in the way they see fit.
-Well stated.
-Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-This is our last
question, and then I
want to leave the last word
after this question to Shelley
Lowe.
Thank you.
-Hi.
I'm Jen [? Durnwater. ?]
I'm also
Cherokee Nation of Oklahoma.
So yay.
I have a question,
but then I also just
want to just quickly say I did
master's thesis in Alaska, so I
can speak-- I'm certainly not
going to speak for anyone who's
not myself and my tribe.
But I do know that the
rates of sexual assault
are so high there that one
of the weekly free papers
that you can get in Anchorage,
it actually every week
has a rape report with a listing
of all of the sexual assaults
that have been
reported to the police.
And I've never encountered
that anywhere else in the US.
So yeah.
So my question, you
touched a little bit
on about men and
culture, and how
to get our men more organized
and involved in fighting
against assault of women.
So you cover that.
But the other question
I had is, what can we
do for indigenous women
who live in urban areas
to fight all of the
abuse that we suffer.
Because yes, we
need to address what
happens on reservations,
and reserves in Canada,
and so forth.
But so many of us are urban,
and we're still experiencing
a great deal of violence.
And yes, technically,
the law is supposed
to be there to protect us.
But it certainly doesn't.
So what are your legislative
or policy ideas on that?
-I think criminal
justice systems
need to be reformed generally.
I think we've seen disparities
in enforcement and means
of enforcement across
communities quite recently
in very intense ways.
And so I think that
our discussions
about criminal justice should
incorporate Native women,
they should
incorporate Native men.
Because the statistics
are equally as troubling
across minorities.
And so that's one solution.
But I think in
addition to that, there
could be a culturally specific
legislative solutions that
do look at the
particular problems
the Native women face
within urban centers,
and the fact that they're
taking with them this concern
about government involvement
to those urban centers in a way
to address that concern and the
way police interact with them
in particular.
-And this might sound
really abstract ,
but I truly believe that the
restoration and recognition
of our tribes' inherent
sovereignty to protect tribal
citizens and including
its own Native women,
when that legal
framework shifts,
I think we'll see either
as a result of or as a part
of, or maybe the
driving force will be,
a cultural shift the United
States where women go from
being sexual objects to be
abused to being actual citizens
to be respected.
And I think when you look at a
lot of the way our Native women
are depicted in American
culture, I mean,
they're just a Halloween costume
right now in the United States.
Literally.
Or maybe really like
a Pocahontas kind
of character in a Disney movie.
And so I think when
we're talking off
of tribal lands and the
rates of domestic violence
against our native
women in urban areas,
I think at the root of
that is the legal framework
and the cultural
misunderstanding that
perpetuates from that.
When our tribal sovereign
nations aren't real,
then how can how can any
American citizen conceive
of their women as real?
And I think that's the
problem we're facing.
Thank you.
I'm going to leave the final
word to Shelley Lowe, Executive
Director of HUNAP.
-Thank you.
I just have some books,
actually, to give out.
I want to give a shout out to
the National Indigenous Women's
Resource Center in Montana.
They have been major, major
supporters to this play
and to Mary Kathryn.
And it's very important
to them that this play be
performed and heard everywhere.
So on behalf of them
and thanks to Harvard,
I want to acknowledge
a few people.
There's information about
this book on your chair.
It's Safety for Native Women,
VAWA and American Indian
Tribes, and it's published
by the Resource Center.
I have one for
each of the panels,
and I won't ask you to
come here at the moment.
You can stay there.
I have one for Aharon and
Esther, for all their hard work
on behalf of NALSA.
You guys can come
grab yours real quick.
[APPLAUSE]
-As students, they took time out
of their busy, busy, busy, busy
schedules to help us
do some fund raising.
We want to thank them for that.
Bringing this to Harvard
is a feat all in itself
I think sometimes.
It was very powerful
as you've seen.
But it's also something
that you really
have to convince an institution
that, yes, we should do this.
And I want to thank
Dan for helping
with that as a conversation.
Thank you, Dan.
But then we have
to thank Radcliffe.
And the first person who we
had to talk to about this,
and we had to say,
come on, this is good,
it fits our thematic year.
Let's do this.
And she said, yes,
let's do this.
I want to thank Becky Wassarman.
[APPLAUSE]
And more importantly.
Becky then said,
yes, let's do this.
But we have to get the big,
big, big approval, which
can be kind of scary sometimes.
You're like, a
OK, OK, all right.
And she was pitched the
idea, and she wholeheartedly
said yes, even when
she saw the budget.
So yes, we are at Radcliffe
tonight for a reason.
And Dean Cohen, I want
to thank you for that,
for being such a great support.
[APPLAUSE]
And for being here all
evening with us, thank you.
And lastly after we got
it, and we were set,
we were ready to go.
We sent little personal
notes to the provost
and the President of Harvard
and said, we're doing this.
Can you support us?
And they said yes.
So I want to think Provost
Garber, and President Drew
Faust for their support.
I have the book here
for Provost Garber.
I'm going to ask Associate
Provost Lori Gross.
To come and get this.
We will send President
Faust, a book to her.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, everybody for coming.
I hope you enjoyed it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]